Is this game on?
Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Alright, so they're doing a briefing right now, so we're just listening to the briefing at the moment.
If you guys are like, wondering what the fuck is going on...
Oh, uh, for the map, it's Stormpoint.
So we're just, we're just getting briefed on what we have to do and what we...
What the fuck?
Oh, my bad, I thought I was muted.
I just need you guys to know, this custom, I feel really bad for the organizers, because like...
My teammates, other than Short4, my teammates changed like...
Uh, three to four times.
So like, um, I was supposed to have Wots...
I was supposed to have Sweet, then I was going to have Wotsy...
Then I was going to have Repz...
Then I was going to have Enemy...
And then finally I have Vermont, and I found that out this morning.
This is our host.
Oh, it's Clump.
Is he still talking?
He's still going, yeah.
I think he's still talking.
Wait, really?
I agree, Mandy.
No, yes, Mandy, I agree.
Oh, wait, then Mandy, like, deafened himself?
Really good, yep.
Mandy, that's... yeah, that works.
This is really important information.
I hope you're all writing this down.
No, hold on, Zero, you have to let Mandy speak.
Did he just mute his corner?
Yeah, so like, yesterday I thought I was going to have Repz...
Guys, guys, please let Mandy speak.
And then I woke up, and then the organizer was like, Teehee, JK, we're going to be playing with Enemy.
And I was like, cool!
Cool, is Enemy going to be my pro?
And then literally, like, three hours before the custom was supposed to start, he was like, Teehee, JK again!
It's the host!
And I was like, oh, okay.
What is Twitch?
People have already, he's not even reading it.
So I'm just like...
They're like debriefing.
While they're debriefing, you guys are going to listen to this debrief while I make my waiting room for my other lobby.
Mandy, you've been muted for like five minutes.
Wait, he's still muted.
Sound ports are so bad.
I didn't disable it, but...
Wait, why does it say that girl is talking, but I hear Mandy's voice?
Because it's coming through girls.
Oh, you can hear him through my face?
Oh, you're locked up.
Wait, that's like she was trying to profit right now.
Hold on.
Are you actually Mandy?
Rig the games for us, bro.
Oh, true.
I'm not.
He's not.
You've been muted on Discord.
He's literally deafened.
You're deafened.
I'm muted now.
No, you've been muted ever since.
I'm not muted.
This guy is a Zoomer.
We can't hear that at all.
What the fuck is going on?
Discord doesn't use Discord.
They can't hear you?
What are you talking about?
Alright, I'll see you guys tomorrow.
Goodbye.
It's cocked.
Good games, good games.
What's happening right now?
Well, like they're having issues with...
Manny is like muted right now.
We hear you.
Oh, damn.
He hates us then.
He's not talking.
His mic is broke, bro.
Why is it going green but we can't fucking hear anything?
What's going on?
I don't see it going green.
It's going well so far.
It's going...
It's going pretty well so far.
Now we can hear you, I think.
Yeah,
he went on like a soliloquy and we didn't hear like 10 minutes of it.
I think I'm ready to play.
We don't need this.
We know the rules for game one.
Yeah, we know the rules.
Alright.
Alright, do we have code out?
Is code out?
Do we leave?
No, doesn't seem like it.
I don't think so.
Yeah, code's coming in in a sec.
I can start... keep working.
Okay, the waiting room is here.
Wait, can you guys hear my game?
It's time to check out the fan... the Dragoon fan game.
Multitask time.
Lessons we brought up.
And there's a ton of people.
Okay, sure.
No problem.
Can we like chill and wait for him to figure out if he can talk or are we going to our channel?
Honestly, just hit the... just hit the... oh, wait.
Oh.
Wait.
Okay.
He's cooked.
Everyone just go to the service.
It's cooked.
I'm going to my channel, bro.
Alright, bye everybody.
Great talk.
There's a code out.
We're off to a good start.
Yeah, I think... you know what?
That might be the only, you know, bad thing that happens today.
Everything else would go... everything else would be like, you know, would go okay after that.
I don't believe you.
Why?
It's not about believing in me.
It's about believing in the organizers.
Okay, but like it's not about believing in me.
Do you not believe in the organizers?
The leader is the only one I know.
I'm not even the team leader.
We're all randomized together.
There's no team leaders in this.
This is random royale.
Okay, why is the team name Code Doki?
Because you were like... you picked the team name.
So I was like, alright, I'm shilling my gamer subs code.
Guys, okay, do you know... wait, are you streaming Surefour?
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Surefour chat, do you know that I have a gamer subs code where you can use my code DokiBerry for 10% off on any order?
Have you looked at my chat enough to realize they're all just gonna spam no?
No, they won't.
Because I'm anime.
You got a Dice of Cringe, you got a no.
Guys, are you really gonna listen to Surefour?
No, they don't listen.
They listen to themselves.
Are you really gonna listen to Surefour and let him tell you what to do and what not to do?
Look at that, I see... I will buy some right now.
And you're like, fuck Surefour.
I see your chat and they're like, yeah.
It's like one person.
You're cherry picking.
No, I'm not.
I saw at least two people.
I saw at least two of them.
Oh, the gamer code is up.
How do I copy it?
Why is my Discord broken?
Okay, let me fix this real fast.
Oh no, fix yourself now.
Can I copy it because I don't have permission to send messages in the chat?
Wait, what?
No, you can't.
I literally just copied it.
Dude, it's not letting me.
Okay, the first letter is P.
What's our... where are we?
We have a leak, bro.
Oh, the first letter.
There's like freaking 10 numbers in there.
Okay, that makes the statistics go wrong.
Alright, the last number is 7.
Do I have to hide my screen?
Good luck, everyone.
No, it's asterisks.
Okay, if it gets leaked, it's your fault.
I literally did it on stream.
Wait, it's Stormpoint, right?
For the hide and seek map?
It's a map.
Alright, you guys know the hiding spots for Stormpoint?
You're talking a first place here.
You got first?
On the very first...
I think it was disguised host.
No, my team was first in the very first disguised host.
First round, I got first.
Oh, the first round.
Okay.
Yeah, I was like, I remember I got first place on that.
Oh, so this is basically winner's POV.
Virus is in here.
Wait, my name's still Ice King.
I'm not changing it.
You got some phlegm there?
Alright, I'm gonna...
I wanna be Pathfinder.
I just hope you're okay.
I'll be fine.
Let's see, am I missing...
Oh yeah, I was gonna finish my work tweet.
Work tweet?
Yeah, I need to tweet out my waiting room for my stream after this.
That's in like, a different time.
Yeah, but I still need to tweet out the waiting room.
Alright, done.
Oh no, is this the right...
I'm pretty sure Dyrus is just gonna look for you to grief you, by the way.
But he doesn't even know what I'm playing as.
It doesn't matter, he'll stream snipe.
He's gonna stream snipe just so I can...
This is like, three years.
He waited three years for this.
It's something he would do.
What's the team that's... Who are the Seekers?
The Gamersubs team, so Sov's team.
Oh, Sov's the Seekers?
Yeah, like all the Zz's.
That means we gotta rely on luck on the last zone.
We literally have to rely on last zone to see who fucking lives.
Do we know we're team Doki... Wait, is this Dyrus?
Is superidiot5000 Dyrus's team?
We're superidiot5000.
I think that's Dyrus.
Yeah, because he's with Fun.
I don't even see superidiot5000 in the team names.
Oh my god, is that actually him?
It's with FunFPS.
Oh yeah, that's probably him.
I guess we don't have designated landing spots, so we can literally land anywhere we want.
Yeah, we just rip it.
It's just all separate.
What's the strategy, guys?
Surefour, lead us to victory here.
Oh yeah, Surefour, since you've won that game.
I mean, we need an AUK team for griefing.
You need Horizon for getting juicy highgrounds.
You could go Pathfinder for more juicy highgrounds.
Yeah, I claim Pathfinder.
I have a feeling the zone is gonna go all the way to endgame.
No, 100%.
I mean, with the secret team?
It does.
They're definitely not gonna kill everybody.
I mean, they're not allowed to use scans either, so...
And also, who the fuck is Willy on their team?
Whoa, bro, whoa.
I'm just asking a question.
Who's Willy?
That's Ellie, bro.
Oh, is that Ellie?
That's a VTuber, bro.
You're fucked up.
Willy is Ellie?
No, it's not.
Oh, you're looking at...
I'm looking at team 20.
Yeah, I was like, who the fuck is Willy?
Dude, the last thing you were talking about was Dyrus, super idiot 5000, fun FPS, okay?
I was like, there's a Willy in there.
I was like, no.
Ellie is literally called Ellie.
I don't know.
Why don't you type in chat, who are you, Willy?
I think they're all, like, actual gamer subs, people.
Yeah, probably.
Oh, so we are gonna make it to end zone.
Dude, you guys are toxic.
It might end up being, like, a heal-off.
I think it's literally gonna be a heal-off at the end of the game.
Yeah, like, I legitimately don't think...
And if they don't play ballistic, they're gonna run out of ammo before...
Listen, the only way we win a heal-off, one of us has to be a support character.
Because support characters get double heal from syringes.
Mmm...
Alright, Surefour.
I don't want to pick one of the team and play Loba.
I think Loba would be the best one to play.
Alright, Surefour, it's time for your heal-slut arc.
Like you said, he'll take one for the team.
Oh, you're gonna take it for the team?
Oh, so you're gonna be our heal-slut.
Come on, let it out.
Yeah, let it out.
Say it.
Don't let her bully you.
The person that plays Loba is like, time a syringe.
Alright,
so what are we playing?
I'm Horizon.
You're Horizon, I'm Pathfinder, and then Verhulst is our little Loba.
Are we trying to like, stay together?
I thought we were splitting up.
We're about to be across the map.
I'm pretty sure it's...
We can stay in the vicinity to craft armors and stuff, but like, when we get into the thick of it, just hide.
It's every man for himself.
Yeah, I feel like this is like...
I guarantee they're not gonna be able to kill anybody.
If everyone's on Pathfinder and Loba, they're not killing anybody.
They're not gonna actually kill anybody.
Oh my god, you have zero confidence on these guys.
I really don't think they're gonna kill anybody.
What if you're gonna be the first person to die to them?
What happens if you're the first person to die to them?
Are you gonna retire from Apex?
I'm not playing the rest of the tournament.
You're just gonna leave?
Oh no!
He's not even gonna come back for BLGS, guys.
He's literally just gonna...
He's just gonna disappear off the face of the earth.
I'm just gonna retire.
Why isn't Manday one of the seekers, bro?
No, he's just casting.
He's just watching us like a...
We're like little rats to him.
I legitimately thought Manday was gonna be in the Gamersubs team.
Because this entire tournament is based off of Gamersubs.
They might need it.
Honestly, I was surprised.
I was surprised it's like...
An actual full team of Gamersubs people and Sov.
Wait, where are they gonna land, though?
Where...
Where are seekers landing?
I think they'll probably go to the edge and give us a little bit of time or some shit.
Yeah, that's true.
Pretty sad one of us just got landed on.
It's 3pm somewhere in this world.
What are we missing?
We're missing like three people.
The seekers are splitting up.
Good luck.
Oh, we're splitting up?
No, they're splitting up.
I don't even have zero chance of killing anybody.
Oh!
Not even a last chance.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
That's one.
Yeah, we don't know how their aim is.
Wait, if they're not Apex players, then like...
Like, do you think they can even hit us?
We're about to find out.
It doesn't matter whether they can hit us.
Like, they're not chasing a pro Pathfinder.
Yeah.
I'm just like, would anybody be able to hit the pro players?
Any pro player that's on Lobo or Pathfinder or Octane, they are not getting chased down.
They're gonna be...
Oh my god.
That's fucked.
I just realized I was using the wrong overlay.
But yeah, that's fucked.
What are you guys playing?
When he's on Pathfinder?
I'm on Pathy.
Okay.
What are you unsure for?
Horizon.
Yeah.
What's the Horizon thought process?
You going for like a high spot somewhere?
Yeah.
Interesting.
I'm looking for a tall mountain with a tiny rock sticking out of it with a tree slightly brushing over it and then hiding there.
Should I just go...
Should I go under the map?
It's like a bug on Lobo.
Oh my god.
Wait, they don't have rules against us.
Yeah, do that.
I'm pretty sure they do have rules.
No, they don't.
No.
I read the rules.
They have no rules against it.
You should do it.
I don't think it's gonna matter because if you're not right where the zone ends, I don't think it's gonna matter.
Oh, wait.
You can't leave, right?
When you're under?
I don't think so.
Oh.
Maybe, yeah.
Maybe you shouldn't.
Don't worry.
I brought it up to the admins.
Wait, you snitched on us?
I can't believe it.
Surefour is a fucking snitch.
No, I only snitched on you.
I can't.
I only snitched on you.
We're a team!
It's hide and seek.
It's every man for himself.
Yeah, but it's a team game.
If we win, we get money together.
Nah, because if you guys die, then that goes away and it's only to me.
No, it isn't.
We all get it.
Are you kidding me?
What?
Okay, I need to fix my overview.
Two seconds.
Wait, are we starting?
I'm tapped out.
Two seconds.
Wait, they're missing one.
Who is...
Oh, team five starts.
No, they're not.
They were about to, and then someone was missing.
You can't...
If you wanted secret...
Wait, what?
Can we get...
His keyboard got muted this time.
Can we be secret?
What does he mean with, if you wanted secret?
We'll never know.
We'll never know what he meant by that.
Will we ever get to start the game?
Let's find out.
Sorry, I got the winter throat disease right now.
Oh no, that's the worst type of disease.
It's not too bad.
No, it's the worst type.
I meant when he's like coughing.
I guess, yeah.
I mean, as long as you like mute yourself.
No, I was trying to say to him like, it's okay that he's coughed on mic.
It's not that bad.
Just trying to comfort him.
Oh, I wasn't.
Well, yeah.
I'm trying to mute it, but sometimes the winter throat disease just slips out.
Yep.
We just can't contain it.
Yeah, you gotta let it out.
You gotta let it out or you'll have too much inside you and then you'll combust.
Yep.
I can't be combusted mid-game?
Nope.
I like how they're like, if you could put GamerSupps x Mandy and then use code Mandy, by the way.
Guys, use code DokiBird.
I also have a GamerSupps code too.
Don't use that.
And you get like...
Why not?
Don't use that.
How do you use code DokiBird?
So you go to...
Okay, so it's very easy.
You go to GamerSupps.com and then from there...
Oh, wait.
No, sorry.
GamerSupps.gg.
And then you pick...
Oh, by the way, I also have merchandise at GamerSupps.
So you can actually look at my collection.
Oh, wait.
Sorry.
It just got off the market.
It literally ended today.
But there's other really cool things on the website.
So you see all those cool cups over there.
Skip.
Skip ad.
YouTube skip.
And then you can also see these jugs where you can get some cool GamerSupps flavors.
And then after that, you go look at the code.
I pressed the skip ad button.
Skip.
And then you put the code DokiBird on there.
Skip ad.
You get 10% off on all your orders.
Skip.
But yeah, use code DokiBird if you want 10% off on all your GamerSupp orders.
I'm drinking GamerSupps right now.
And I say that it's really good.
Are you gonna buy GamerSupps stuff now, Surefour?
Skip.
I'm drinking a fucking C4 right now.
A C4?
What the fuck is a C4?
Whoa, conflict of interest.
What's a C4?
It's a pre-workout energy drink.
Oh shit.
Is it good?
Does it even taste good?
Yeah.
What flavor do you have?
Zero sugar.
Starburst.
Cherry.
Starburst?
Whoa.
It's got 200mg of caffeine.
Okay, that sounds like a lot of caffeine.
I'm about to explode like a C4 charge right now.
Yeah, is that why it's called C4?
I'm literally fucking busting with energy right now.
I can't wait.
You're gonna have so much energy for fucking hide and seek.
Oh yeah, I'm motivated.
Oh my god, it's been 24 minutes.
It's been 24 minutes, please!
You signed up for this.
You signed up for it too!
Yeah.
And I guess Verhulst got peer pressured by Mandy.
You got peer pressured?
Oh.
No, I volunteered.
Oh, you volunteered?
Yeah.
There goes Doki lying again.
Oh, I said I bet.
I didn't say like I know for sure.
I gotta make sure I'm picking Pathfinder because...
Alright.
Ice King.
Where the fuck is he?
You're the wrong teammate on our team.
No, that's me.
Why are you Ice King?
Because he's the Ice King.
That's his side job.
It's PGA lore.
PGA?
PGA.
PGA Tour Golf?
Yeah.
I made a guy that was dripped out.
Called him the Ice King.
Proceeded to shit on all my friends.
Ooh.
Ice King, King of the Green.
Alright, so they're landing at a random spot.
So I guess...
Alright, where do we drop and drop lead?
Do we drop with each other or do we all leave each other to die?
We probably drop with each other at the start.
I think we can stay relatively close.
We don't have to stay on top of each other.
We should be relatively close.
Okay, I don't want to meet Jumpmaster.
Bro, you fucking relinquished it so late.
What's your fucking deal?
I didn't realize I was in my settings.
What is your deal?
I was in my settings.
I didn't know.
I'm gonna land here then.
This is a great spot.
Alright, let's see who dies first.
Yeah, just be wary of landing next to anybody.
You don't know who's the seeker.
Well, this person looks like it's a solo flying on me.
I mean, the seekers were all going to be split up though, right?
Yeah.
I feel like a lot of hiders are splitting up too.
I think we're good.
I'm taking a gable.
Wish somebody should pick up the yellow thingies.
Oh, ult excels?
They said I'm allowed to use horizon ult.
Yeah, as long as it's non-damaging.
Someone's in my building.
If you punch them, they'll never know.
Do not use names.
All I'm saying is if you punch them, they won't know who did it.
That's the thing.
I think they'll know.
They'll never know.
I'm going to punch one right now.
Alright, do it then.
They won't know it's me.
Just be like, who's that pathfinding that punched him?
Alright, I'm here.
I'm not.
Evo Harvester online.
Ooh, yeah, we should get the Evos.
Alright, let me boost up my...
Try to get red armor.
That'll be huge.
You can get red armor.
I'm low balled in here.
I'm here.
Ooh, I got the Evo Harvester.
Yeah, it's just some friendly fisting.
What's wrong with that?
A lot.
What?
As long as both parties consent, then it'll be fine.
So, can you not pick up shields anymore?
You can pick up shields.
What do you mean?
Oh, you mean like farmer swaps?
Just like stuff in general.
I'm going to get that Evo Harvester.
I'll get that one.
Okay, I pinged that one.
I literally dibs it.
Oh, there's a guy here.
What if I just fist him?
By the way, if any of us die, you can just go craft.
You can instant craft one of us.
There's really no risk in running around.
You can literally just run around and do whatever you want.
Try to get all the Evos.
I don't even know what an Evo Harvester looks like.
It's yellow.
It's literally yellow.
I pinged it and you're just stealing it.
You're just not fast enough.
Wait, it gets it for all of us.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh my god, it doesn't matter.
It's literally not a competition.
We're a fucking team.
I thought it was mine.
Wait, what's with battery pack size?
We're at the end here.
We can't be split up at the end.
Wait, are we allowed to do ring consoles or no?
Yeah, yeah.
Just no damage anything and survive.
That's literally it.
Wait, so I can do survey?
I guess.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright, I'm going to fucking access survey.
If they say you did this or did that, just blame Manday for being muted for like 19 minutes.
That's so true.
Okay, but I feel like, I don't know, I think survey is not that helpful because there's so many high days anyway.
You get Evo for hitting it.
I do, but I can also get Evo for doing ring console and we can fight end game.
I hear shots.
I hear shots to the north.
We got a Seeker in Jurassic.
I'm going for this Evo on the outskirts.
I'm going crazy.
Oh, he's going to go wild.
I have so many meds.
Yeah, what's going to happen to us?
Die?
That would be silly.
Okay, I'll do ring console.
Wait, there's a death box here.
Someone was like, but there's more survey.
It's alright, it's too late.
I wonder how many players are actually hiding.
There's no way anyone is actually hiding right now.
Surely everyone is just getting Evo.
What is the pink thing on the map?
Nobody is hiding.
Everybody is just getting armor right now.
Oh, I got a care pack baby.
I'm going to get a Kraber.
I'm going to go get this Evo.
Wait, if the Seeker is trying to kill you, just drop the Kraber for them as like a peace offering.
Wait, Linkster died to Sov?
Oh, Linkster got finished.
He didn't just die.
He got finished.
Finished.
Damn.
That's sad.
Noob down.
Alright, I'm going to do the ring console.
I might die for this if there's somebody there.
Do I do my tactical cooldown or my ultimate cooldown?
Probably tactical.
I think your tactical is more important.
But like, think about the griefing opportunities.
Is this person following me?
What am I punching right now?
I'm just a cereal puncher.
I just punch every random person I see.
There you go.
Oh, next ring.
Spotted.
The Seekers aren't allowed to hit man scans, right?
No, they're not allowed to.
Well, they said they're not allowed to play characters who can do it.
That's really good.
Wait, there's heat shields!
Yeah, I got one.
Alright.
I could just sit in zone for a long time if I didn't have syringes.
I got hella medkits.
I have... I have a decent amount of meds on me.
Oh wait, how does that just register?
We have heat shields?
We definitely need heat shields.
We all need a pair of heat shields actually.
Yeah, I have a heat shield on me.
I don't have one yet, but... I'm looking.
You're a Loba, you can... you can...
Yep.
Do whatever.
Where's the next ring console?
Try and save... save the crafters.
Like, because if one of us dies, we might have to craft banners.
That's true.
Alright, Surefour, that's your job.
Where's another ring console?
No, I'm the hider.
I'm so far.
Like, there's one here.
Make it head to the other side.
Get to fucking running.
I don't know if I should start hiding.
Someone died out of bounds?
Maybe AFK?
Alright, I'm just gonna start hiding here.
I know a good rat spot around this area.
Wait, yo, where's my scan for the next zone?
Okay, I'm heading over to the next zone now because it's on the other side of the map.
I feel like I could actually go on zone and... I'm gonna scan it in zone.
Oh no, that's just the ring killing the dragon.
I mean, I could scan in zone.
What's the worst thing that could happen?
I die?
They didn't say we're allowed to go in the ring, right?
They didn't make any rules against this?
Nope, they made literally zero rules.
They made not a lot of rules for this one.
We can take advantage of a lot of things.
I hear shooting.
Wait, where are you?
What color are you?
It sounded like the shooting was over here.
Alright,
how the fuck do you have rad shield?
I found a care package.
Alright, I'm scanning for us.
Rad shield in a minute.
Alright.
It's right here.
Alright, looking for my rat spot.
Wait, there's that one spot in the spider cave.
Did they ever fix it?
Well, time to find out.
Alright, I need you guys to give me some meds.
No.
What do you mean no?
They're mine.
I sacrificed my life to give you guys a ring.
It looks like they fixed it.
I think this person was trying to do it.
I actually don't even remember where it was.
Do you guys have any shots around you?
Nope.
On my ping.
I guess you don't know which one is my ping.
I heard shots over here.
I used a crafter, so...
Whoops.
That's awkward.
Okay, so you're trolling.
That should be fun.
Heard.
There's no crafters in Sound 3 anyways, so...
By the time one of us dies, it'll be too late.
That's true.
I don't hear any shots.
Dude, where am I supposed to hide?
They have so many invisible walls now.
I believe in you.
Well, I know one gig of rat spot, but like...
What's the worst that could happen?
They shoot you?
They have no pro in their team.
The zone is not going to end where you're at.
It's going to keep pulling out towards the middle somewhere.
Yeah.
Alright, I'm heading over there.
I don't see a gun on him.
I'm going to sacrifice myself by running in the open so Verhulst will know if there's a person near me.
Am I able to hide on this tree?
Wait, I don't think they can look up.
There's a lot of skinny trees you can get on top of.
Can I hide here?
I saw Valkyrie trying to do it and it looks like she was just phasing through them.
Wait, I hear shooting.
There's a guy on my roof.
What the fuck are you doing here?
What if I punch you right now?
Oh my god, what do I...
Wait, what characters are the seekers on?
Do we know?
Nope.
No.
Dude, the fucking branches are invisible.
They'll never know.
How would they know?
Where the fuck do I hide?
This place sucks for hiding.
There's a seeker right on top of me.
Oh shit, wait, where are you?
He's chasing me.
I think he's at Octane.
Okay, so we know one of them's at Octane.
I'm pretty sure one's on Path too.
I think it's on Octane Path.
Oh my god, there's so many people running in right now.
There's so many people running in.
There's people here, but it's just a regular guy.
Where the fuck do I hide though?
Look, there's only one player dead.
No, there's two.
Two players.
Oh, I think they like res people too.
Yeah, they res.
I think the resing was a bad decision here.
It's gonna go down to end game for sure.
It's gonna head to end.
There's no way.
I think I saw only like two people actually die die.
Oh, there you go.
Good job, Todd.
You did it.
Guys, we have to move into zone.
They're not gonna have enough ammo.
That's what I'm saying.
They need a ballistic.
If they didn't have a ballistic, it's over.
I don't even know if a team of three pros could kill an entire lobby.
No, they could.
If you have a ballistic, you can.
I literally just did a custom with hide and seek.
If you have a ballistic, you have non-stop ammo.
Like infinite ammo.
Dude, there's no hiding spots on this end game zone.
It's just gonna be everyone running around and I'm just gonna throw my ult.
It's like literally in the open.
Hey, who the frick are you?
Get out of my frickin' spot.
Stupid Pathfinder.
Oh shit, guys.
It finally went to 15.
We're good.
I hear people.
Dude, no one's even hiding.
Everyone's just running around.
He's right here.
Right here, where I'm peeing.
That's him.
I'm hiding in the building with you.
I'm getting away from this guy.
Dude, you're running into another one, too.
Dude, there's no hiding spots around here.
I'm telling you right now.
There's zero hiding spots.
Also, the most likely hiding spot is the best hiding spot.
Because they're like, ah, no one's gonna be in there.
Like, who's gonna check in this frickin' house, bro?
Exactly.
They're too busy.
There's like so many people running around.
Yeah, they're too busy finding all the frickin' rats.
There's a guy right here.
He's coming up behind you!
He's at the spider cave!
He's gonna get ya!
THEY'RE TAKING FIRE!
WILLY'S TAKING OUT TWO!
There's one guy here.
Stick around here.
I'm here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Keep pinging him if you guys see him.
Ah, fuck.
It's moving.
There's gonna be so many people in the spider cave.
What do we do, Surefour?
We're a little fucked over.
I'm just waiting until the last second.
Fuck it, bro.
We're gonna die to the ring of death.
I'm gonna thrive in the chaos.
That's my...
That's true, that's true.
I think, like, in the end...
This building is probably bis, bro.
That building's probably bis.
They're not gonna check that shit.
Yeah, that's right.
That's true.
You should go there.
Wait, how would you even make it?
You're so far.
Uh, running?
We have armored zips!
You're right!
Girls, please.
You can't die.
You're literally our trump card.
You're literally here to survive.
You're a support.
Nah, nah, nah.
Not that I know of.
I mean, there's a bunch of, uh...
Excuse me, you guys have to evacuate soon.
Nah, nah, nah.
They're not gonna check the building.
They're just gonna keep...
Dude, there's so many rats outside, there's no way they'd come in.
I have, like, four other people in here with me.
We're gonna have four other people with you.
Oh!
He's in here!
They drew him into me!
They're griefing me.
They closed the door on me.
There's one over here.
There's one over here, too.
Yo, come res me.
No balls.
Bro!
He's gonna finish you!
Nah, nah, nah, nah.
They're chasing someone else.
I don't know where they are.
Oh, okay!
Okay, that's so helpful!
They thirsted me.
Oh my god, and you wanted me to head over.
You wanted me to head over!
I got griefed.
They closed the door on me.
I told you not to go in!
They made the person come into my spot, and then they griefed me!
I told you.
I told you not to come in.
I told you not to go.
This is why you can't trust human beings.
What if it was a VTuber, though?
They only want to see the worst in the world.
He's right here.
He's right over here.
I see you're here.
Wait, do you have a res beacon?
Bro, everyone's stealing your G.
I know, I know.
I'm just strengthening my army.
You're strengthening your army?
This has not turned into a hide-and-seek event.
This has turned into just, like, a manhunt event.
No one's hiding.
Everyone's just running around.
I gotta stay close to the pack.
What if I finish this guy right in front of me?
What if I just...
Res me up.
If I finish him, they won't think I'm a seeker.
Uh-oh.
Uh -oh.
I'm getting up here.
This is a safe spot up here.
Did you just kill someone?
No.
You have 115 damage.
He was gonna die regardless!
I swear, he was gonna die regardless.
I swear to God.
That's fucked up.
No one's hiding on this screen!
It's just a body of people!
They must be out of ammo already.
There's no way they're not out of ammo.
Dude, they're gonna have to start punching people.
How am I supposed to shoot his office?
There's, like, rezzing.
Somebody's fucking rezzing in the open.
Oh my God, there's a guy, like...
Someone's gonna touch you.
He's gonna touch me.
Wait, where the fuck did these guys come from?
Some of these people are, like...
Wait, land on the fucking rezz, bro.
The hiding spot up there.
Hide in the fucking rezz spot.
Oh, you're landing on fucking doom!
No!
I'm good, I'm good.
I hear someone with Sheila.
Bro, what is going on?
This is...
I told you, this isn't hide and seek.
This is manhunt.
Bro, somebody is a Sheila right now.
Oh God, they got gunned the fuck down.
Look at these guys.
Oh my God, they have nades and everything.
Dude, imagine if I have Horizontal right now.
Imagine if you're still alive.
Bro, I got griefed, man.
It's fine, you guys got this win.
You guys got this win.
What if I finish on this guy right here?
Bro, there's just zips everywhere.
This isn't hide and seek at all.
Oh my God.
Where am I?
They're starting to whittle us down.
They're running out of ammo for sure.
They've resorted to shotguns, bro.
Oh no!
No!
Don't die!
Oh no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
You survived?
Nice.
Survived?
Wait, some people are resing right there, bro.
Where's our res at?
We didn't get you better!
Guys, I think they actually ran out... I hear zero shots.
They 100% ran out of ammo, bro.
Why does that guy have a bow?
You can't let them access this.
You have to close the shop down the moment...
No, he put the shop down so they could have ammo.
No, oh no.
Yeah, he's trying to help them out.
Yeah, that's what I'm telling you.
You should have grabbed that Kraber and gave it to them as a peace offering.
That's true.
What if I get a Kraber from your thing right now and just shoot one of them?
Don't die!
Uh oh.
Not good.
Oh?
I think it's endgame.
I think this is endgame.
We're good, we're good.
Hey, one squad's out.
19 squads left.
Butterfly knife melee.
Yeah, they definitely don't have...
Dude, how are they supposed to kill any of the people zipping?
Maybe ability shouldn't have been allowed.
They always have abilities.
Uh oh.
Oh no.
No!
Alright, it's up to you.
It's up to you, Doki.
No, I can't heal up.
Doki, don't!
Just look at them!
I can't see him!
Survive!
Look at his banner!
You can heal, you're good.
Oh shit.
No!
Dang it.
I died to zone.
Dude, that was focused.
I was trying to heal!
I couldn't!
It touched my foot!
Dude, what is this, man?
I told you they needed ballistic!
They had no ballistic, they can't live!
They're not even gonna win the game.
They're gonna get like 15th.
How are they gonna find out who won?
They have a leaderboard at the end.
Bro!
Look, my game plan...
We bet on Evan to live, but...
They're all dropping like flies now.
Game over.
I don't even think the Seekers survive.
Of course they...
I bet a fucking...
Yeah, I bet a fucking Hider won!
No, the Seekers definitely...
I watched the Seekers, they got like 15th.
No, look!
Fun won!
Wait, Dyrus won!
Dyrus won!
Dyrus actually won!
That's like crazy!
Wait, the Seekers came in like in 9th place!
I can't believe it!
The Seekers are 9th!
Only top 3 got points, right?
Yeah, well, top 3 wins money.
Each game is like its own prize.
Yeah.
That's fucking hilarious.
Aw, Wraith would have been a god tier player.
I didn't think about Wraith.
Yeah, you just keep fucking...
Yeah, we planned on...
We planned on Wraith hulking the entire time, but that didn't happen.
I panicked.
My foot touched the zone.
Wait, wait.
Team 2 got 3 kills.
Team 2?
How the fuck did Team 2...
They...
How are they getting 3 kills?
Yeah, how did they get...
Yeah.
Hmm...
Wait, what the fuck?
Team 5 literally has 2 pros.
Wait a minute.
That's fucking life, isn't it?
Who's supposed to be on their team?
Well...
Wait, they're missing a VTuber on their team.
Wait a minute, this team doesn't even have a VTuber.
They're getting penalties.
Like, they can only play with one gun or something.
Game 2 is standard ALGS custom match.
Oh, so it's just a regular game.
Alright, what do we play?
Do we do...
Do we do the support shit?
The meta is Gibraltar, Catalyst, Newcastle.
Alright, I call Gibraltar.
Throwing cover for Roberto.
Trifor, you got some good Newcastle gameplay?
Never played them once in my life.
Okay, to be fair, you haven't played a lot of characters.
That's true.
I'll play whatever.
Alright, what do we get?
What do we do, IGL?
Oh shit, we gotta claim stuff?
We gotta claim drop spots.
Yeah.
We're on world's edge.
Well, I'm going to the washroom.
I don't know if anyone is playing Clowntizer, but I'm claiming it.
Oh, someone claimed it.
Guys, I didn't do anything.
See, I have zero kills.
Look at my name.
Zero kills, right there.
Are we just...
We're playing what?
Newcastle, Gibraltar, Catalyst?
Alright, good talk.
Yup.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
I'm just reading through the POIs.
I'm trying to actually get us a POI.
Wait, somebody else tried to claim Clowntizer.
Yeah, we're going to go SkyWest Trials instead.
Okay.
Wait, did you claim it already?
Yeah.
In the game chat, but...
Alright, I double claimed it.
Double claimed what?
All of SkyWest.
I'll even say all of SkyWest.
Oh no, I'll be like SkyWest East.
So then they'll think I'm...
They'll think that like...
I'm a different team.
Surefour doesn't type anything yet.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Surefour, type SkyWest East.
So then they'll think like there's two teams already.
I got it.
Nice.
I think Zero's trying to contest SkyWest.
Unless he's like fucking around.
He's on Zero's team.
Oh, they have...
Zero, Nasty, Meek, I mean...
Do you guys think he can handle Nasty?
Or Zero?
Wait, Zero's team has two pros too?
Well...
What the fuck?
What happened to their team?
What are you talking about?
Team 11?
Yeah, and Zero has...
Oh yeah, they...
Wait, their entire team's different.
A lot of people dropped out last second, I guess.
Oh no, that's Zero plus.
Oh my god, there's too many Zeros in this world.
Zero's ahead in the game.
You didn't even notice.
I don't even know.
There's like four teams already.
I'm with the guy.
Why is nobody here?
Why did people leave?
They hate us.
Starting game, everyone's here.
Yeah, we might get conned by like four teams.
Oh shit.
That's good.
We just have to frag out.
Why is that good?
Yeah, but do they have Verhosto on their team?
That's the thing.
True.
That's so true, right?
Did you guys take any Adderall before we played today?
I haven't taken it once.
I'm scared to take it.
I'm scared to take it because what if I become too ascended and I can never go back?
Yeah, but don't you want to...
Don't you want to feel what it's like to be a god?
Wait.
What if I take steroids?
Wouldn't that just like...
Is it true that steroids like shrink parts of your body?
Yeah, it shrinks your balls.
Wait, just your balls?
Yeah.
Oh shit, wait, why does that...
You deal with everything else.
Oh, I mean that's a...
That's a good compromise.
I get high.
You also die at a younger age because...
Your heart's going overdrive and shit.
Oh, that's true.
Your heart gets bigger, right?
If you take steroids because it grows everything.
You get super jacked.
Yeah, but then you get super jacked.
So, I mean, doesn't...
Don't most pro wrestlers take steroids?
Like The Rock?
Is The Rock on roids?
Yeah.
Maybe.
I mean, look at him.
Yeah, I think most WWE guys are on steroids.
I just look at the thing with people on steroids and I look at their traps and it looks like a little person in like a meat suit.
I'm so...
Oh my god, this...
I'm going to be late for Mother's Stream.
I feel like we're going to be like...
Like a 15 minute break every game.
And then Saab was like, don't worry.
We're going to go fast.
We're going to go so fucking fast.
You know how these things fucking go, man.
I thought it'd be different.
He said it would be like super fast.
Like we're going to go so fucking fast.
Well, sometimes people get lied to.
Yeah.
I'm so...
I'm so happy to be here, guys.
We could literally play Subway Surfers on the side right now.
Hey, yo, hop on Webfishing.
Oh shit, wait.
Did they fix the thing where hackers were like...
Hackers were like going into people's servers and doxing people?
They weren't going into my servers, at least.
Oh shit, okay.
What's the code?
Let me launch real quick.
Guys, hop on Webfishing, everybody.
Let's all go on Webfishing together.
Let's have like our...
My fan base fight Sureforce fan base.
And also Overhaul's fan base.
I'm pretty sure mine play video games.
Mine play video games?
What are you trying to imply about my fan base?
Oh, you know.
No, your fan base can't play video games because they...
And they vicariously live through you.
Okay, so what are yours doing then?
They just think I'm funny.
Oh.
The code is N P Y T 2 K.
N P Y...
Can you say it again?
T 2 K.
N P Y...
Okay.
Alright, I'm going in.
I'm going to the docs.
It's loading in.
The server is marked 18+.
Are you guys in too?
Dragoons, are you in as well?
Yeah, you can ERP on this server if you want.
Dragoons, you hear that?
You can ERP.
Yeah, of course you would say that.
But you're the one that suggested it.
Yeah, it's a suggestion.
Yeah, and I'm telling my dragoons that...
And suggestions show people's moral compasses.
Yeah, so, like, dragoons, if you really want to, it's 18+.
Alright, who is a dragoon in here?
Listen, I've seen random art of people that they draw of you.
Guys, wait.
On my 4-year page.
These people are freaks.
Wait.
I think air traffic control is one of the hackers.
Is it?
Ain't no way.
I think he's the one that doxxes the airport.
Doxxes the airport?
Ain't no way they're just watching your stream waiting, bro.
I'm scared.
I mean, they left already.
Yeah, there's a thing.
There's a thing where some of the hackers would...
They would literally, like...
Wait, am I even in your server?
I don't know.
Did I join the wrong one?
I'm pretty sure you are, because I saw you join.
Oh, okay.
I'm at the doxx, Brit.
Where the fuck is the doxx?
Do you even play web phishing, bro?
I played it one time.
You noob or what?
Nobody's talking, though.
Why is nobody talking?
You can't talk.
We're cats.
I'm a dog.
Ew.
What's wrong?
What's wrong with being a dog?
I see you guys.
You picked a fucking dog?
Yeah, what's wrong with that?
Bow, bow, bow, bow.
Bow, bow, bow, bow, bow.
How are we still not...
Oh, wait, we're starting.
Oh, shit.
Guys, wait, we're phishing.
We're phishing, guys.
Wait, I just got here.
Oh, shit.
I got it.
Dog clutch.
Alright, there we go.
There we go.
Hey, guys.
I'm here now.
Why is nobody talking, guys?
Oh, it's because I was on local chat.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
Well, time for an exodus.
Killing everyone.
Oh, okay.
Who's left the game?
Alright, now we actually play.
Just jump faster.
I'm really pushing.
The plan?
Yeah.
That's the most experienced.
One of us can go north.
One of us can go south.
And the other guy goes trials.
I'll probably just go...
I think some people were saying they were going trials in the chat, though.
Yeah.
Yeah, they're gonna get slammed.
Alright, godspeed.
I'll go north.
I believe.
Because I'm from the north.
Alright.
Wait, where am I supposed to go, again?
I don't know, south or something?
Wait, do I follow you?
Oh, okay.
What if we get fucked?
Well, if we get fucked, we get fucked.
That's life, isn't it?
I think we're good.
I'm pretty sure we're good.
I don't see anyone.
Are we split off, then?
Alright, then I'll loot here.
One of you can go north.
One of you go south.
I'm north.
Team SkyEast, okay?
Just be careful.
I'm going here.
Just, like, loot away from SkyEast.
Like, start in the middle and come left.
Yeah, sure, four.
Start in the middle.
Okay, that's not middle.
Don't worry about it.
Wait, what's the meta guns right now?
The Nemesis, Triple Take.
Oh, yeah, Triple Take.
Yeah, Triple Take is so good right now.
I saw everybody playing it.
Triple Take is, like, the best gun.
What's the secondary, then, for it?
Mastiff or Peacekeeper or Eva.
Alright, I'm going to aim for...
I hope that Mastiff is the best.
I'm going to aim for Mastiff, then.
Oh, shit, still hard.
Wait, isn't that Dyrus' team?
They're already eliminated?
I don't think that was them.
They already got eliminated, okay?
I don't think that was Dyrus' team.
No, they won first place in hiding.
That was their team name.
Was it?
Yeah.
You pretty sure?
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
I think you're lying.
I'm not lying.
They're no longer hard, yeah.
I'm hard.
Whoa!
I'm hard in the paint right now.
Damn, in the heart?
I'm getting motivated.
Oh my god, everybody's fighting.
There's going to be like...
There's going to be like only 10 teams left in Zone 1.
I hear someone shooting.
Oh, it's you.
No, it's not.
Oh, that's him.
Is there a triple take in there?
Nope.
I'm trying to find a triple take, too.
There might be, actually.
I can tell you in a sec.
More people are dying.
Dying is cool.
A lot of contests.
We should get the evil harvester whenever we can.
I don't want to.
We have to.
How many teams?
There's 20 drop spots.
How are you guys contesting?
Because they just wanted to freaking be white.
They just wanted to freaking go ham.
We should've just landed on somebody, to be honest.
True, true.
Take that 50-50.
We all love gotcha.
I don't know how my character works.
You press Q and then stuff happens.
I'm coming.
You're by yourself.
I'm coming slowly.
We're all heading over.
I'm here.
I'm here now.
I don't know what to do with it, but I got it.
Where are they?
He's got one.
Nice.
He's almost got another.
I'm pushing the other side of this wall.
I got one.
Got him.
Nice.
Nice job.
I accidentally have toggle aim on.
This is bad.
Toggle aim?
Why do you have that setting?
My settings got reset.
My settings got reset today, so I didn't fix everything.
I'm going.
You can do it alone.
We don't have to pull you.
I'm on the way.
Oh my god, how do I do this?
Increased revive move speed?
Say less.
Okay, I need a...
Okay, what do I get?
Fast shoties or big brother?
What do I change?
The shotgun one.
Where is my right click?
Toggle...
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Now it's better.
What team even was that?
I don't know.
The shotgun one?
Yeah, get the shotgun one.
I did zero damage.
By the way, there's a gold bag in here.
You can run through that.
Let's go get this guy there.
I'm coming.
I'm slow.
Nice job, guys.
What do you mean nice job, Doki?
Surefour wasn't even here.
What was he doing?
I was running.
All right, sure.
We're going to give you the 1v3 for this next fight.
I was running to get an evo thing.
Guys, who did we kill?
And then a fight started.
Guys, we need a no.
I need no so I can boost my own ego.
What the fuck?
I claimed that.
Come, come, come, guys.
Come, come, come.
Well, I don't give a fuck.
Whoa, it does not respect pings.
I'm fucking cool like that.
I'm holding over.
I have too much stuff.
I don't even know what a gold bag does now.
It holds more stuff.
Wow.
All right, we're close.
Take this gold helmet, Doki.
Yippee.
I'm getting shot at above.
Bubble, bubble, third bubble down.
Okay.
We're just going to slide down.
Yeah, slide into buildings here, okay?
Wait, they have triple take?
That's legal.
I'm about to use your Q, Surefour, on the way down.
You're good.
We're going to avoid that team.
They have a good spot.
We're going to run through skywalk and go east.
Okay, cool.
Heard.
They're trying to slide down, maybe?
They are sliding down, actually.
Wait, they want to fight?
They might try fighting us.
Yeah, keep going east.
Let's go to this building here.
Fucking nerds.
We can definitely slam that team if they keep coming out this way.
Let's try and get to this building here.
Okay.
Someone died to zone.
Let's go to the south here and try and get behind them.
Okay.
I think they're just trying to hit the console.
If they are, we can hold them out and actually kill them.
Heard.
No, they're not in console.
They're here.
Batting.
Not in a good spot here.
Me too.
They're just trying to fight.
They're trying to fight.
Go to this forest door here.
They're pushing.
I broke one.
Come back to this forest door if you guys can.
I'm trying to walk you across.
I'm crossing.
Oh, my game just froze.
Hello?
Oh, that's not good.
I don't think Surefour is going to live, but...
You're alive.
Congratulations.
I'm going to take...
I need my ult.
I'm going to go to the roof here.
Me too.
I'm on the roof.
Do we see them anywhere?
I don't have a lot of energy ammo.
Kill one.
Kill us.
He's down on the crate.
Down on the crate.
I can't.
They shield him.
I'm sending.
I can ult this.
Oh, fuck.
I hit the wall.
I broke one.
I'm sorry.
Dead here.
Nice.
They're trying to run away.
They're trying to run away on the crate here.
They're running.
One almost broke.
He ulted.
He's dead.
Almost cracked him.
Nice.
Got him.
Okay.
I dropped down and hit the fucking...
Oh, my God.
I hit the wall.
It's fine.
Let's go, guys.
Look at that.
Let's go.
Oh, yeah.
Apparently, kill points matter, by the way.
I kind of like the volt.
Grab the volt.
Really?
I would not recommend it.
You have to take this mask if I'm commanding you.
I need energy ammo if people find any.
Because I have like...
Oh, yeah.
What do I get?
Bubble bunker or baby bubble?
Get the one that lasts longer.
I think it's the one on the right.
Whatever one adds plus four seconds.
Yeah, that's the one I got.
I am so poor.
There's more shield bats.
I have like 19.6k shield bats.
Can you drop me some?
I only have two.
Thank you.
I'm going to drop four syringes here.
We're all running energy.
We're cannibalizing each other.
By the way, if we're ever in a sketch situation, Doki, you're just going to throw bubble down.
Like if we're like...
All right.
I'll tell you as well.
Let's try and walk forward here.
Walking.
I'm gum gum.
We're going to peek this building.
All right.
We need energy.
We're going to take this building here.
I don't think anyone's here.
If someone's here, you just bubble and we run away.
Energy.
Well, shooting from across.
We'll make it.
Got my shotgun ready just in case.
I'm going to climb on the roof here.
Just got to run.
Nobody's hiding.
There's energy.
Team's on blue armor over there.
I guess it's 63.
I can't really do much poking right now.
Do you know what armor he's on, Sherry?
What armor was he?
There's more bats here.
There's a team here.
One of them was on blue.
I want to loot these bins, but it's a little...
The team across the street, right?
That's what you're talking about?
Like this team?
Yeah, this team.
Okay.
He's behind that bin.
We might just end up killing them, honestly.
All right.
You guys do all the poking because I only have 100 bullets.
He's on blue, 21.
If I knock somebody, we just kill this.
All right, cool.
I'll look back here.
Wait, what the fuck?
I guess I won't look back.
I'll look back here, just in case.
Someone should look at our right.
There's an all-out thing here.
Our right's clear.
Right side clear.
I'm looking at left.
Our left's clear.
One has red, one has red pushing you.
Yeah, they're trying to walk up.
Our left and our right are clear.
Can we...
I think we just try to kill them, honestly.
I'm down to push whenever.
They're going back to that one spot.
Yeah, they're going back to you.
Tell me, tell me.
Flash?
Oh shit, you guys are...
Nice, good, dude.
They're hard pushing, they're hard pushing.
I'm really far, though.
I'm throwing nades.
I'm peeking inside of this room here.
I hit nothing with my nades.
Watch that castle, watch that castle.
I'm batting.
Yeah, you're good.
Oh my god.
I got one.
He'll be down.
On me.
Castle one, castle one.
I think a new team.
Come inside the truck, come inside the truck if you can.
I need heal, I need heal.
It's just a pathfinder, it's just a pathfinder.
Okay.
I think that's the last guy.
Is that the last guy?
Yeah, I don't think it's a new team.
I think we're good.
Okay, thank god.
I wasn't sure.
Wait, there's a new team to our right, though.
Yeah, yeah.
We can kill them, too.
They're not pushing, they're not pushing.
I am...
I'm just listening to the calls of my leader.
Oh my god, get me in there.
I think we're chilling.
I need to get in there.
Try and scan around, make sure no one's on us.
I need energy.
Here, I have...
I dropped some.
Thank you.
Thank you for donating to the poor.
VTubers.
I think that was the pathfinder.
I think that was the team that...
That was just one pathfinder left.
She lost the zip.
Here, look at this, look at this.
Two left, two left.
Last one, last one.
I remember 100, you can still kill this guy.
He's cracked, but...
Can't get the last shot.
He jumped off an...
Kill this guy, kill this guy, kill this guy.
How many kills?
Flash, flash, flash, flash.
Good job.
Does he have energy?
I'm good, backing up a bit.
No, he has no energy, he has no energy.
No.
I'm gonna get a kill.
You can maybe kill that duo now, there's a duo in the middle of the map.
It's cool.
There's a hemlock here if you want to swap.
Yeah, I'm gonna swap, fuck it.
There's no point.
It's 53, 53.
I'm looking to peek on these guys over here.
Yeah, if you see that duo, let me know, I might be able to kill him.
They're pushing over there.
Gibby's really low.
They domed.
I'm looking at him.
The dome's gonna get... they're running now.
Wait, there's someone close to us, no?
Nevermind.
They ran off, they ran down.
Nice kill.
They're gonna rez.
Yeah, they're gonna rez, that's fine, I can't do anything about that.
Where do we go?
It's a little risky.
There's a team right here that's crossing now.
That's getting shot at.
We're getting shot at right here.
I have an Evo.
Blue armor, blue armor, this team, full team, blue armor.
Cracked them.
We need to go far away right now, I think.
We need to go far away right now.
Come, come, come.
You want me to Evo?
Or Evo?
Nope, nope, just follow me, we're gonna walk it.
Alright.
We're gonna mirror this team on the right here.
Okay.
And if we can't end up killing them, we might have to just take an Evo back.
Yeah, just let me know when you want to pop.
We can also just run and kill that blue armor team.
Except if you said they're on blue, we can definitely kill them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, they're on blue.
Walk up to the other, there might be a team in front of us.
Get ready to slam them instantly.
They had a fucking... shotgun bullet.
Get ready to peek the other shore, we might insta-kill one here.
They're gonna be in front of us.
There's two seconds behind.
3, 2, 1.
One shot, one shot.
Dead.
One more.
Man, I hate the triple take.
Nice.
Finish.
You wanna swap?
Alright, listen, we're gonna kill this team on the left here, there's a blue armor team.
Wait, he's still on the thing right there.
Yeah, then shoot him.
Come to my side, come to my side, we're gonna kill this team here.
Alright, coming.
Come to me, come to me.
We're fighting these guys to the right, but I'm coming.
Okay, I'm coming over too.
They walled, they walled, wait, they're pushing us, they're pushing us, they're spraying us!
You gotta throw bubble up here.
I am, I'm pushing.
Okay, listen, we need to walk up to your Q, okay?
They're pushing, they're pushing, they're pushing!
Okay.
Okay, I'm coming.
He's no armor.
Oh!
Shoot.
That was a duo, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we were pushing them, but then we came to go to you.
Yeah.
Dang, I didn't think they'd come back.
I didn't think they would come back too, yeah.
That's why I was, like, shielding.
I was looking at him, but I think it was too late.
That's so ballsy, like, what are they doing?
That's so ballsy of them to just push!
If we're lucky, we might still get third, like, we might have the third most amount of points.
That's true, but the other teams...
Why did they push that?
That's so aggressive.
If they're doing traditional LGS scoring, we just got 12 points.
And usually a third place team doesn't actually get that many points, so we might actually still end up getting some prize below that.
Nice.
Yeah, I can't believe they pushed that.
I was like...
Yeah.
I had a feeling they were going to push it.
Because, like, you know, they got me super low.
I don't know what team that was.
That was very surprising.
I got shot in me ass.
It's alright.
We can get them on...
Well, we know we can fight a lot of these teams in general.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, now we know the skill level.
Yeah, maybe we'll look at them.
We'll get a third here.
And not a lot of teams have kills.
In general.
Yeah, we basically...
Well, the next...
Well, to be fair, a lot of them were pushing us.
The game mode after this is kill race.
Is it kill race?
Oh, really?
Oh, that's good practice.
The one that's going to die is so fast.
Yeah.
That's really...
Wait, what map is the next one?
Do we know?
I don't know map.
It doesn't say in the little info thing.
They're just like...
You know, I feel like this map today.
Kill race seems like a fun game mode.
Yeah, for the people who can...
For the teams that have like...
Apex players.
Yeah.
Other teams are literally praying.
Some of these teams are pretty stacked.
Yeah.
I mean, some of these teams literally have two pros.
So, it's like...
And some teams have like one pro and then two non-Apex players.
So, it's like really weird.
There goes pineapple pizza.
Pineapple pizza!
No!
Five!
Which team is this?
I can't see names.
This is streamer mode.
This is LGLGS mode.
Oh, this is Zero's team.
Zero.
This team doesn't have a lot of kills either.
Three, four, five, six.
They have six kills.
Most likely, they might be first.
Yeah, they have six kills plus fifth place.
So, if they get one more kill, it messes up.
So, they kind of have to die here.
Okay.
Wait, someone killed them now.
Someone.
We're stream sniping them.
Their location is here.
Oh, it's end zone.
Wait, five teams?
No, they're in a really good spot.
They're not going to die.
Five teams?
No!
Where are they?
Oh, yeah.
This team is...
Oh, and they're working those guys.
Goodbye.
Yep, they're...
Yep, they passed us.
I think this team might get first, honestly.
Yeah, they'll probably end up winning this.
They're in a really good spot.
Yeah, they have a really good spot there.
The other teams are about to kill each other.
Oh, they're taking the balloon, that team.
Oh, they're aiming for second.
Wait, they're just cycling the zipline up top.
Nobody's shooting them, too.
They're too confused.
Where the hell's the last guy?
Is it just a solo?
Oh, they're fighting.
Oh.
Ow.
Oh, Zero's team won!
Yeah!
That was a very, like... what's the word?
Anti-climatic, like... endgame.
It was not very exciting.
I know, compared to what we just had, the hide-and-seek endgame.
There's 60 people jumping around.
Dude, I feel like half the lobby died before the first zone.
They just literally just walked up and won.
Alright, how many kill points did the other team get?
Seven?
Whoa.
We got nine.
Oh, but then team eight has nine kills, so...
We got 12, so 12 plus...
Yeah, but team eight has nine kills.
We tie in third with the third place team, so we tie.
Oh, but what about... Oh!
I don't know who gets priority.
We had more kills, but they had higher placement.
I don't know how that works.
Probably placement.
We got 12 points, and the team that got third place emotional damage, they got 12 points as well.
Yeah, but then our kills were cooler.
Nobody else got 12 points other than team three.
And team one and two, obviously.
Yeah, let's start a riot if they don't split it with us.
I went to tiebreaker.
That's not going to work.
Do we win?
Come on.
I think they win because they get higher placement.
That's usually how ALGS does it.
That should be illegal.
I agree.
Kills are cooler than placement.
Placement is way too boring.
How long until the next game starts?
Do I load up web phishing?
Alright, what's the code?
What is this game?
Web phishing?
It's free!
It's just phishing.
It's not free, right?
I don't remember.
It is free.
Oh, it is free.
You get to fish with other people.
Other cool cats and dogs.
Yeah.
Like one of those .io games, like a website game?
No, you gotta download it on Steam.
It's not free, sure.
It's like $7 or something.
$5.
Oh, yeah, it's $7 Canadian dollars because our money is paper money.
Alright, what's the code?
I'm freaking loading it up.
What is the fucking code?
MX88PA MX88?
Yep, 88PA.
PA.
Alright, I'm in.
It's web phishing time, guys.
Guys, it's R18.
Remember what that means?
ERP.
It's time to ERP, guys.
Hey, guys.
Are we going to the docks?
But I don't want ERP.
It's too late.
You clicked agree, guys.
You know this is an R18 server.
I always go to the docks.
Yeah, but last time...
But this time, this is Sureforce server and he loves ERP.
That's why he creates these servers for people.
Oh, Gibraltar's banned, apparently.
We can't play Gibby anymore.
Ooh, did they post a ban?
I don't know.
Someone in my chat said it.
Oh, Newcastle, Gibby, and Lifeline are bad.
When do we play?
Newcastle, Gibby, Lifeline?
Okay.
What is the...
next rule set?
Let's see.
Does anyone have a guitar?
Can anyone play us some music?
Someone might have one.
Any guitarists here?
Any guitarists?
No musically inclined fishers?
What are you guys' best characters, what do you say?
You're the Apex pro.
I can do Bangalore and...
For a while, I did Rampart and only griefed people with a charge rifle when it was hits.
Oh yeah, I remember that era of Sureforce.
Oh shit, I got an octopus.
Octopussy.
Look at that.
Have either of you played Thieves?
I played them like two or three times.
I can play Pathy, Wraith, Bangalore, Catalyst, Conduit.
I think we just do Bang, Horizon, Pathfinder.
I can do Path.
I can do Bangalore, yeah.
Pathfinder?
I'll do Bang.
Is the goal to just instantly kill everybody?
Yeah.
We're gonna run them down.
We run them down or we die, that's it.
Or would you rather play Pathfinder or Doki?
No, I'd rather prefer Bangalore.
I don't like Path's new hitbox anyway.
Yeah, he's pretty big.
Nice.
What did I get?
I got a soda can.
Oh my god, and there's money in there.
Why is there money in the soda can?
I don't know, maybe like, if it's for good luck.
I basically yoink somebody's luck from the sea.
What?
Wait, there's two game threes in this infographic.
I see.
What game are we playing next?
It's Kill Race.
Is it Kill Race next?
You can boot up a second PC, we're playing both games at the same time.
Yeah.
Oh, true, true.
We basically clone ourselves and then go to a different lobby.
Any team that eliminates Team Gamerselves will earn $250 bounty.
Whoa, where are they landing?
Let's get a drop spot.
Oh wait, the drop spots are being called right now.
Oh no, no, no, no, no.
Baits from Cohen Heights.
Please tell me nobody called it.
I think we got it.
Oh no, I don't have any bait.
Can anyone donate some bait for me?
No.
Can anyone send me some letters?
With bait in there?
I'm not talking about you, Surefour.
I'm talking about the people in my...
Oh, Alan!
I know you, you're from my stream.
Give me some bait.
Well, my viewer said, not a dog.
Dirty dog.
Whoa!
Alright, if you're a dragoon, swap to a dog.
We're having a dog versus cat war.
I can kick anyone in this game.
Alright, you guys pick your characters.
We're about to load here.
Oh shit, okay.
Oh shit.
You're on Bangalore.
I got Bang, yeah.
And you're on Horizon.
Horizon.
Yeah.
Oh shit, where's Bangalore?
Oh, there she is.
Top left, top left.
Alright guys.
We're just going to all land on the rooftop.
Alright, cool.
Yeah, I don't know if Surefour has.
I'll have to look when I load in.
He's still fishing.
Oh, never mind, he's gone.
Listen, we're about to three man land on a rooftop and another team might literally land on this rooftop with us.
And we're just going to pick up a gun and just do it without.
Gulp.
Oh my god, you're right.
Surefour is willing to kick dogs?
Damn, that's fucked.
And I'd do it again.
Alright, we're going right here to this building.
Can't see it, it's on my ping right there.
We're going to that rooftop.
Alright.
Oh, match ended.
Alright, match ended.
Yeah, I guess I should just...
You should what?
Low tier god.
Scrims!
I love scrims!
Low tier god.
We wait.
We fucking wait.
Oh, someone picked one of the banned characters, I guess.
Oh.
They're really spamming that.
Just so everyone knows.
Bam, Newcastle Gibraltar lifeline.
Oh, a VTuber did it.
I knew it.
It was Reinho.
Who was it?
Exposed him!
Call him out to the world!
It was Reinho.
She said she was alt-tabbed and then x3'd.
Damn.
Kick her out.
Any OG Seers?
Alright, starting now.
Are you an OG Seer or an OBG Seer?
An OG Seer?
An OBG Seer?
Yeah.
What is that?
Have someone post it in your chat and then look at it.
OGC, OBGC?
OGC, OBGC.
Guys, what does that mean?
It looks like someone playing with their thang.
What?
Yeah.
OGC.
Guys, nobody is posting it!
Oh, your chat is lame.
Is that like a boomer thang?
No, it's not a boomer thang.
Is that a boomer thang?
It's not a boomer thang, bro.
It's lowercase OGC, capitalized.
I see it.
I relinquished.
I can see it now.
I'm going to do a test here.
Alright.
This is a really far flight path.
We might not even make the roof here.
I believe in your ability to stretch.
Yeah, I believe in you.
Because we're just going to stick to you until we make it.
This is West Coast server.
Fuck EU players, I guess.
Trifor, you're going to land on the left side of the roof and grab a gunspawn.
Doki, you're going to land on the close bin.
There's a really close bin on the roof here.
Are you going to land on that?
Okay.
I'm going to go to the right.
I'm on the left side.
Yep.
I don't see anyone here, though.
I think we're good.
Yeah, I think we're good, actually.
I don't think nobody landed on this.
Doki, you can go left here.
Okay.
Trifor, you go to the right.
Just leave all these buildings on the right.
Does placement count in this, or is it literally just kills?
It's just kills, I think.
Okay.
I'm going to hit this man scan here, and we're just going to go around to the closest team.
Alright.
Whoa, people are fighting!
Holy shit, so many people are fighting.
I know.
What is going on?
We're just going to get one kill and inserted.
Oh, two scrubs, one pro dead.
That's the team that killed us.
No, that's not.
That's not.
We killed them.
They literally have like three teams that's like the same name, but like worded differently.
A lot of fighting.
Wow.
Can we kill farm?
That's the plan.
Are we going to respawn farm somebody?
Yeah, yeah, we spawn farm them.
Who's bad enough, you think?
Yeah, like we'll just leave one person alive every time.
And then follow them.
This is why kill races started not being popular, guys.
All people did was kill farm.
I don't know if you see a nemesis or a flatline.
I got a nemesis.
Oh, there's a massive though.
I hate the triple take.
I'll take it.
I know, I dropped the flatline earlier.
You'll kill people with it.
Thank you.
Promise.
I can give you a vault, Surefour, if you want it.
A what?
I can give Surefour the vault.
And then I'll take the triple take.
Make sure you grab the salt bin ducky when you're done.
Oh, they already killed the gamer sub team.
That was fast.
No, our fight money!
Oh no, I have $250.
Oh, we don't have any evos.
We need to get this evo together.
As soon as you get this assault bin...
Let's go get this evo together as a team.
Surefour, do you want the vault?
I got one.
Oh, wait, where did you drop the triple take?
He had the triple take.
Oh, I thought you gave it to him.
No, he dropped the shotgun.
It's up here in front of the bin somewhere.
I see it.
I got it.
There's another nemesis here.
Someone wants it.
I got the triple take.
I just need a scope for it.
Alright, I told everybody we're here.
I'm duck hunting.
Alright, I'm gonna go hit this beacon real quick.
And then if anyone's on this beacon...
You want tactical cooldown or ultimate cooldown?
Tactical.
Alright.
Dang, we have nobody.
What?
What the fuck, man?
That's so late.
That was so late.
What happened?
I don't know.
I'm taking a piss, bro.
A teammate picked Lifeline.
Somebody picked Lifeline.
It's we the people's team.
But like, why did they restart so late?
What?
Wait, it's not we the people?
What happened?
Their team died and restarted.
Look at the characters.
Who did it?
I'm looking at we the people right now.
I don't see anybody.
Nobody did it.
Yeah, nobody did it.
Why did we restart?
Literally, no one had it.
Five people crashed.
Two DCs.
Not me, so I don't care.
I'm getting pissed off.
I think because it was a West Coast server, so I think maybe the EU players crashed or something.
I'm Alt-F4 and I'm OGC.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
Do we save for them to wait?
Nah, fuck it, bro.
A lot of teams are on conduit.
It's not a bad pick.
Do either of you like playing conduit?
Which ones?
The conduits?
She gives shields.
I've never played her.
I could try her.
You don't have to.
If either of you guys like playing conduit, you can play her if you wanted to.
But I think our comp's pretty dang good.
Match starting in 4, 3, 2, 1.
I almost want to just land next to somebody and just kill them right away.
I feel like if we don't kill someone early, we kind of want to snowball.
Hey, I'm down for anything.
I might just have us land on Stadium and we just kill them.
I don't know who's landing on Stadium.
We haven't started yet!
I went to the bathroom!
It says starting server.
Okay, now we start.
Nice.
I might just have us run at a team and grab a gun and just send to this team.
Which one?
The Stadium team?
I don't know who's there, though.
It might be a double-pro team.
I don't know.
It's okay.
I'll say I crashed if we lose.
Yeah, good call.
Trick or treat, you're the same.
Wait, what's happening?
If we lose, I crash?
Yeah, we'll be like...
If we land on top of somebody and if we lose, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll be like, sorry, I crashed.
Can we restart?
I'll just say I picked Lifeline.
Yeah!
They can see if you picked Lifeline!
Nah, nah, nah, nah.
They can't.
Just say you have the newest skin on.
It looks like you're not Lifeline.
Yeah.
It's a visual bug, but I was definitely on Lifeline.
I crashed and ended up playing Lifeline.
My game looks fucking bugged, bro.
Like, this is crazy.
Where are we landing then?
We're just gonna do the same thing, I think.
Alright.
I don't remember where it was.
Was it here?
Up here, yeah.
Don't split off yet until nobody's coming.
Doesn't look like it.
There's only one team to our right.
So we're gonna push out.
Every team landed far side.
By the looks of it.
There's a team here, and there's a team behind us.
Yep, just try and loot fast, and we're gonna go.
Alright, going back to where I started.
Hope I get good shit.
Oh, there's a flatline here.
I probably got that.
I'm gonna get the same guns that I had.
I had a Mastiff and everything.
Oh my god, I get worse guns.
Oh, nice, triple take.
Okay, I got my triple take.
A lot of teams died earlier this time.
I think everyone got a mole again.
They all learned their lesson.
Everyone was like...
Everyone knows where to go now.
So you got the Assault Bend Duggy.
Behind the... maybe.
There's a Nemesis here too.
Do we have any Evos at all?
Nope.
Oh my god, we don't have anything.
We're gonna blend together and get this Evo over here.
I need a Mastiff.
I need a shotgun if anyone finds one.
Nope.
No?
Okay.
Fuck me, I guess.
Who cares about what I want?
Oh, I found a Mastiff.
Let's go.
I'm here.
Where do we go?
Just make sure you smoke right away.
Okay.
Where are we going?
On the left here.
There was a team that landed there.
Oh, they're over there.
See them?
No, I saw the little glowy thing.
See?
Yeah, they just hit the map room.
I'm gonna get this Evo really quick.
I might end up fighting this team.
I'm here with it.
Me too.
And they saw us too.
They're on the left here.
Yeah, we can maybe...
I don't know if we're gonna fight this actually.
I shot him.
There's a guy to our right here too.
Track the bloodhound.
Backing up.
I don't have an angle.
Are they running?
One of them did.
One guy far right.
Just try and spread out here.
They're really spread by the way.
There's another team to our right.
We need to go south.
Go through the south choke right now.
Just run through it.
Just keep running.
Keep running all the way.
We're gonna go hit this beacon over here.
Okay.
They might keep chasing us.
I don't like that.
I don't like that at all.
See, if we keep running, they'll think we're a weaker team.
And then we can stuff them.
We can turn and burn.
I like that idea.
There's like...
There's a lot of fighting over there actually.
Oh, there is a lot.
Should we go back?
That's too many teams there.
There's a team here.
There's a guy here.
We can kill that guy.
I'll be a solo.
I'm right behind you.
It's probably a solo.
We're gonna hit this.
We're gonna get the Evo.
Hit the man scan.
And then probably kill that guy.
I'm gonna go hit it right away.
How can there be a solo already?
They died.
No way.
I'm getting your Evo right now.
I'll come as fast as I can.
You go to Verhulst.
I'm getting Evo.
I'm still a little lagged.
Wait, the server is lagging.
That's life, isn't it?
I can't move!
The server!
This guy Mirage ulted on me.
I don't know where he went though.
Watch out for you guys that are falling out of the ship, okay?
Guys, I got netcode.
I got...
People DCing!
I'm not the only one.
Nice.
I got another one.
Are you able to reconnect?
I don't think so.
Zero also DCed.
You can reconnect.
I'm initializing.
Cannot rejoin previous match!
No!
Are you serious?
It looks like we're duoing this now.
She's gone, bro.
I'm gone, gone!
It looks like we're duoing this shit, bro.
No!
Duo here.
We should go kill that.
Guys, I'm sad.
They're gonna run their way.
They're gonna go this way.
Guys, it's time to webfish, guys.
We can kill that team.
I'm gonna put a D-Vac down.
We just land on them.
I'm down.
Sad.
Did you get the finish on the guy you killed, Noct?
Yeah, I finished him.
Nice.
I...
Listen, we want to land close to them, but not on top of them.
They're right there.
They're to the left of you.
Yeah, I'm gonna land over here.
I saw one guy behind the building.
Did you see the other one?
I saw one guy go into this building right there.
Yeah, they're on the back side.
One guy here.
Sad.
Can we kill this guy on the left here?
Yeah, I'm coming.
Alright, guys.
It's time to fish.
Right here.
He's cracked on me.
On this rock here by himself, I think.
Is that Bendy?
He's broke.
He's like one shot.
Where's my code?
How do I find my code?
That other person is probably hiding over there.
Yeah, he probably is.
I think multiple people deseed, so there's some teams with two players.
Guys, how do I...
Where's the code?
Oh.
Alright, here's the code.
Here it is.
He just called a moby.
Looking that way.
We can maybe kill that guy again.
You better respawn on this team again.
Do it.
You gotta do it.
They just respawned again over here.
They're too far though.
Alright, guys.
Another guy might just be fucking hiding over here still.
Yeah, he could be.
Let's go fish.
I think one went right and one guy went left.
It's fishing time.
Dogs only.
If you're a cat, I'm kicking you out.
What the fuck?
I see you're a cat.
I need a heavy mag.
Alright.
Get out.
Let's just run around and look for kills.
I'm down.
I have triple take car.
Very interesting loadout.
If you're a cat in my lobby...
See, if you were a cat player, you wouldn't have gotten DC'd.
Prove that you're a dog right now.
Change to a dog right now if you're a cat in my lobby.
I'm gonna cut the makeup.
Boi.
Okay, all you have to do guys to change is you go to customize right here.
Let's go hit this beacon over here.
Yeah, you're gonna get web fishing comms.
Okay, I should mute myself.
Clear comms.
Okay, alright.
If you're a cat, you go to backpack and then you go customize and you pick a dog.
If you do not swap to a dog right now, I'm gonna fucking kick you out.
Alright, good.
Dogs only!
Alright, there you go.
Let's go.
Alright.
It's a dog only world.
Sorry.
Right bow.
If you are not a dog, right bow?
I'm already mad.
Don't make me angrier.
I can't even play the fucking game.
I was looking forward to killing.
We cannot restart this current.
We cannot restart this current match due to time constraints.
Then why didn't you restart last game?
We wanna look for the duos.
We're like one of the only duos right now.
Probably.
The other ones probably died.
That's not good.
That's so bullshit.
It is.
That's why I'm fishing my pain away.
Oh, I still don't have bait.
The third party specialty.
This custom is like so cursed.
I feel bad for the organizers.
Like literally people were dropping.
Literally they got players like five minutes before.
They had to get players five minutes before the tournament was supposed to start.
That's how cursed it was.
Like I got swapped pro players like four to five times.
I was talking about it earlier but originally I was supposed to get sweet and then I and then it was it was sweet then waltzy then reps then enemy and then we got for host like three hours before the custom was supposed to start.
I had no idea like who the fuck was gonna be.
The other person actually knew it was on my team was sure for it.
Little ambush.
No, Tempo isn't proud of organizing.
No.
It's like a whole different team of organizers.
So it's like but I think it's like they're new to organizing Apex stuff.
So like Apex tournaments and stuff.
So it was like like people were like being drafted so late.
Even though it's a kill thing.
Are you guys scared?
You guys are scared?
Nah.
We're playing smart.
You guys are fucking scared.
No.
The dead can't speak by the way.
I'm fishing.
I'm technically alive because I'm fishing.
I'm fishing right now.
I got a guppy.
You could be fishing right now.
It's like a bunch of duos alive.
I just don't know where they are.
There's a rez right there.
Oh, in front of us?
Over there?
Yeah, they're gonna kill us.
Should we look at this?
I'm here with you.
Give me a quiet while.
I'm inventing a new way of fishing.
I'm gonna go for the fan actually.
I'm gonna fin this guy.
I'll come to you, okay?
I feel like I'm playing more web fishing than...
I swear this stream has been like 80% web fishing than actually playing the fucking game.
They're almost dead over there.
I think they're almost dead.
We're web fishing tournament.
This is a web fishing tournament right now.
Look, I got glistening small walleye.
What a guy!
Where's my little guy?
I know I had one too.
There you go.
I put my little guy with you guys.
Look at that, all our little guys are together.
Oh, I can grow big!
I'm gonna be the biggest dog out there.
I'm gonna keep growing big.
He's one shot.
Keep growing big.
There's one to your left too.
It's just like the airline, whatever.
I don't know where he's at exactly.
I heard him moving around.
I think he's in middle stadium.
Oh, I got an alligator!
Look guys!
I want to see my gator.
It's not euphemism for anything.
I never got my kill on that octane.
I got that gator in me.
How do I get this gator away from me?
If I see any cat here...
Oh my god, you're breakdancing!
Oh shit!
I don't think my team's gonna...
It would be funny if I win money by web fishing.
There's one behind you.
They're so fucking locked in.
Guys, if I...
If I see any cat in here, I'm gonna...
No, that's not me.
If I see any cat in here, I swear to god...
Let's see...
It's time to fish.
Wait, you can swim?
You can swim?
Yeah, I shot the guy on your cross.
Tidal only for people who got the super rare golden ray.
Wait, what's the super rare golden ray?
What is that?
Is that why you can swim?
Can I bait?
Why is there no fish?
Oh, there it is.
Let's see, where the fuck is my fish?
We can play doki.
Wait, did you guys win?
Nah.
We got cut off running into zone and then got graybered.
How many kills did you guys get?
We got...
Six, I think.
Yeah, but do they have the kills though?
Yeah.
One person almost has as many kills as we have behind.
Okay.
It's not fair!
This conduit has six kills.
Multiple people crashed too, so it sucked.
That's fucking life, isn't it?
They probably didn't want to restart again.
No, they didn't.
Yeah, but they were willing to restart the last one.
Why did it have to be me?
Better you than me.
No.
Yeah.
No, Verhulst, who would you rather have on your team?
Me or Surefour?
I don't know.
He's not gonna answer that.
But the answer is obviously me.
No, it's not.
If you make a poll right now, people will pick me over you.
Nah, my comms are pristine.
No, they're not.
Yeah, they are.
I have better comms than you.
I actually play the game.
Oh, that's cap.
You don't even play the game.
We came in third.
We came in third on kills.
Wait, we're third?
On kills, yeah.
Wait, then we...
Wait.
Then we win.
It's 13-16 and then 7.
Yeah, then we win.
Because like...
Because like it's all about the...
the kills.
It's not about placement.
Yeah.
Oh, you're right.
We get third.
Oh, let's go!
Let's go!
A fucking new web version, was it?
Why did she get a good job?
She did nothing!
Free money!
This is fucking bullshit.
Let's go!
I'm going non-verbal.
Let's fucking go!
I got free money!
Okay, how do you...
How do you...
How do you see like what placement we got?
The match summary?
But you had to like be in the match.
Yeah, but like I meant like...
Does Madden even say who wins?
Because we don't even know who won the last one.
Because we tied.
I don't know if he's like marking it down somewhere or what.
I was going to say...
It's fine.
We got free money.
DC'd and I still win.
Look at that.
Man, we could have had 20 kills that game.
Yeah, if I was alive.
No, guys.
None of you guys can get a cut.
You were not there.
I wasn't there, but my name's on the team register.
So they can't take me off.
I'm petitioning to get your name off.
You can't do that.
Yeah, I can.
It's a free country.
I'm Canadian, bitch.
I'm Canadian living in America.
I'm playing both sides right now.
Oh yeah, new code.
Almost forgot to join.
They posted already?
Yeah, they posted a new code.
It's in how to join.
It's old school Apex now.
Yeah, they did.
Oh, and we do like...
Watson...
They have specific characters we have to play.
Gibraltar, Pathfinder, Wraith, Watson, Gibraltar.
There's two Gibraltars.
Pathfinder.
Alright, we will be playing the Watson version.
We're playing Watson?
Yeah, we're gonna do the Watson.
I call Watson.
I like Watson.
Wait, does that mean I have to play Gibby?
Yeah.
Oh, unfortunately.
Why can't I play Wraith and Ashe?
Watson time.
Wraith is pretty bad right now.
Yeah, but it's old school.
So it's old Wraith.
If it's old Wraith...
Wait, even the old school option...
They don't...
Revert it to old Wraith?
Is it?
Are they doing that in game mode?
Oh, they are.
That's what I'm saying.
Is it actually gonna give us the old characters?
It says old school Apex.
Yeah, but it might just be like...
Oh, it might just be making you play...
The specific...
That's why I did my last custom.
We actually had it on the...
Old school characters.
It's a...
You can select it.
Yeah, GameCube is getting classic.
Yeah, it is.
I think it is the classic.
Who the fuck is with us?
I don't even know what PUI we go to.
Wait, Horizon Classic is Giga.
Why do we have Reksu in our chat?
Hey guys.
So, really sorry about earlier.
We weren't able to restart.
Due to time constraints.
But we are now using new code.
It's on switching servers.
We're trying to stay on top of it.
If you guys need anything, just let me know.
Alright?
Thank you.
We're really, really sorry.
We wish we could have restarted.
It's alright.
It's Doki's fault.
Wait, how is it my fault?
Other people also crashed.
We got third anyway, so it's fine.
If you guys need anything, just ping me.
Alright, who won the last?
Who were the top three teams on the last two games?
Oh yeah, cool.
Because they don't post the results and stuff.
I'm curious who got...
Because I think we tied for third, so we're curious.
We were tied on third for the second game.
We're doing ALGS rules.
ALGS rules dictate that...
A, single match scores.
Well, since it's one match, we're skipping that.
B, it's single match best placement.
There it is.
Okay, so...
Oh yeah, Verhulst, did you claim your drop spot yet?
Yep, we're going to scroll down.
Oh shit, sweet.
Okay.
Alright, so...
Well, it's OG characters, so do we...
I don't know which one's better.
I never got to play OG.
Wait, you never played OG?
I played OG, I didn't get to play competitive though.
I don't know who played it.
I never played competitive.
OG's fun.
I know Horizon OG is Giga, just sitting on my little lift.
100% being.
Let's see...
I mean, like, Wraith was really...
If I played OG mode, in my custom, and Wraith was really good, Wraith...
Ours had, like, not set characters, so, like, our team went Wraith, Pathfinder, Caustic.
I think Wattson's going to be better, just because Wattson's going to be, like, the only, like, defensive character.
That's true.
If you have Wattson, like, you're going to be completely unpushable.
Yeah.
So, Surefour, you'll just be on Gibraltar.
I'm pretty sure Oldschool Gibraltar's, like, pretty bad.
I don't know why they put Gibraltar in the lineup.
What, you're putting me on a bad character?
Yeah, but you can make him good.
Surefour, you've been carrying so hard, I have to put you on the hard character.
Yeah, yeah, and I DC'd, so I get, like, and then I get a crutch.
Typically, the Gibraltar player has extreme high levels of mechanics.
Exactly.
You have to win every trade you take.
Okay, now you're just lying.
So he's trying to say you're a good player.
No, no, I'm being serious.
It's like Winston from Overwatch.
Why is it like Winston from Overwatch?
Because you put the bubble down, and then you bubble juggle.
Yeah, what's wrong with that?
That's all skill.
That's so much skill.
It's all about having the biggest brain.
You're used to that, Surefour.
Me shotgun in your face.
Don't push me bubble.
You're only bubble for a brother.
You tried to fly, Surefour.
I'm so excited.
Ready up, we're all here.
We don't care about team 10.
Somebody fucking moved their team 10.
You can pre-select your legend here.
Wait, you can?
How?
You have to back out.
I assumed that, but I thought there was some hidden tech.
I know exactly where they are.
This is the OG mode.
We need to find and kill Giga so I can finish her.
Wait, what did she do to you?
Exist.
What about her existence?
They hang out in the Discord every now and then, you know.
Did she do something to you that made you...
No, it's just about killing people you know.
Oh, that's true.
If we see Dyrus, you gotta let me finish him too.
Alright.
We got knocked out first round last time.
That's true.
It might be really tough to get to them before they die.
We're all here.
Start, start, start.
Bunger.
We're so close to them.
Where are we dropping?
We're like next door neighbors.
Are you wanting to go say hello?
Yeah.
Yo, yo, yo.
Yeah, DC last game and we still got third.
Exactly.
Free money, dude.
That's what I'm saying.
Wait, did we actually get third?
I don't even know.
Oh wait, we did?
That's fucking good.
I'll take it, I'll take it.
I was web fishing.
I'm sorry, my mic is fucking... I don't want my mic and shit, dude.
Yeah, you were muted for like 10 minutes that one time.
Yeah.
And now it sounds like S2 or what?
Well, it sounds like you're in an empty room.
Hello, hello, hello?
No, I'm not.
It's not that empty, so...
It's not that empty.
Yeah, but it does sound like you are in an empty room.
Well, we have to pop off.
Thank you.
Alright, thanks, man.
Can you tell us where endzone is?
Oh, okay.
Guys, we didn't win.
We didn't get third on the second game, guys.
But we got third in.
These guys have pride badges!
It's illegal!
Oh, we got a hot tub!
Oh shit, let's go!
Yippee!
No one contesting us, right?
I don't know.
If we are contested, land for the rooftop here.
If we're not, everyone can just go to a different side.
I think we're good.
Wait.
Are we?
There's a team behind us.
We're good, we're good.
I'm gonna go to the left side.
I'm going right side.
Alright, I'll go forward.
And get shot at, I guess.
Oh shit!
Are you kidding me?
Dude, we had hot spot!
Oh my god.
We should get some monetary compensation for this.
This is our time!
Our time is valuable!
I was gonna get a gold gun!
Wait, does that mean it's OG wingman and shit?
Yeah.
I'm getting the R9.
R9 Peacekeeper.
Every gun is busted in this.
Who the fuck didn't select it?
We got two mint.
This is why you shouldn't have... Okay, too fair.
My custom had so many fucking rules.
There's a bloodhound on...
Who do you pick bloodhound?
Team emotional damage.
Who the fuck?
Somebody pick bloodhound?
Isn't bloodhound an OG hero?
No, but we have set characters.
It's just one guy.
We should just let this person like jump off the cliff.
And then they couldn't play.
That's their punishment.
We restarted a game for one team?!
...
You can't pick any character.
You have to be...
There's only two set team comps allowing us to play.
They don't want scans, huh?
They're only allowing either Pathfinder, Gibraltar, Wraith or Pathfinder, Gibraltar, or Watson.
That's the only two comps they're allowing.
Yeah.
We could just let them play.
Just let them play.
Who cares?
It's literally one team.
If they get first place, we fucking kick...
We like revoke their prizes.
Sheeper.
Throwing cover for a Brudda.
Oh, the prize pool for this one?
I think it's just placement.
There's no kills, I don't think.
Yeah, it's just placement.
Oh, shit.
It was Zac.
Zac fucking... We're gonna be going early.
Zac was the one that picked Bloodhound.
Oh, my God.
It was a pro.
It wasn't even a VTuber.
We got fucking scapegoated.
You know, I actually did that twice in one tournament before.
I also did it in a tournament.
Oh, so kills don't count, right?
No.
Well, the main problem is the lobbies take five years to start, and then you're not ready, and then it randomly starts, and then you panic.
Yeah, you have to be locked in and stare at your main menu for ten minutes.
I'm running here.
Okay, so you're just gonna take my spot.
Yes.
Are we running outwards?
If we're running outwards...
We'll be going that way, yeah.
Alright, we'll land there and push out.
I took your spot because I was there first.
I forgot there's no shields on this.
You have to find shields.
Oh, my God.
I actually ran past the shields because I was like, I don't need it.
I forgot about that.
Oh, yeah, and it's just like OG Apex where there's zero fucking loot.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh, I got Skullpiercer.
It's over.
I got my Peacekeeper.
Is the flatline any good in this?
No.
I don't think it was, honestly.
Oh, there's a wingman for you.
Here.
Nice, I'll take that.
I mean, if I had an R9.
There's another wingman here.
I have a wingman.
I'm inging it up.
I need to grab the... oh, find me an Ult Accel because I can get insta ult.
I'm picking up this extended mag for someone later.
Ult Accel on me.
I'm holding two as well.
Oh, there's a heavy mag here.
I got a purple on me if someone needs it.
Anyone find an R9, let me know.
You can't hear me.
I got PK ready.
I'm grabbing this one first.
I have two already.
Should I get three?
Can you stack them?
No, you can't stack Ult Accel.
And like, I have very limited inventory space.
There's another one there.
I wouldn't worry about holding three.
Alright, who wants this purple heavy mag?
I have a blue one.
I'm dropping it right here.
Gonna be for my wingman.
Alright, let me know when you find a R9.
I'm gonna hit this beacon up here.
Okay.
God, this is ancient.
Oh yeah, it is.
Kills don't count, right?
It's all about placement.
Health placement.
Did they say it was about placement?
Because they changed the fucking rules on us.
It just says prize pool.
The top three teams will share a total of 2,500.
Oh, so it's just placement.
Okay.
Dude, they can hold so much ammo.
What the fuck?
We're gonna try and get straight in the middle of the zone.
That is the plan.
I just need...
I need R9.
Pick me R9.
Let's see if there's an R9 in here.
No R9.
I'm a little late in the open.
I'm very vulnerable out here in the open.
My white armor.
Can you take the balloon?
Shoot the last guy?
I think that was the last guy.
I'm gonna take it.
Oh.
I think there's one more.
I think that was the last guy.
I swear to God, it's the other one.
Anyways, we should take this.
I bet.
Alright.
We're gonna go into air base here.
I'm gonna bubble insta if we get shot at.
Fly to the left here.
Someone's landing bottom left.
They're also... Can we land here and cut these guys off?
I'll try.
Oh!
Nah, we can't really.
There's people here.
Can you run over here?
Fall, come to me.
Yep, I can try.
I don't want you guys.
I bubbled just in case.
Yep, that's a really good bubble.
Oop!
I'm gonna chill here for a second.
I'm okay.
Where do we go?
You guys just chill there for a second.
I'm gonna scout forward.
See if anything's free.
I'll stay here.
My little cuppy hole.
I feel so safe.
Come to me.
Coming.
Just run it.
We're running.
I have bubble if we get shot at.
I was greedy and looked at loot.
Oh my god!
Okay, I'm fine.
Armour swap?
I'll get the armour swap.
I'm grabbing it now.
I don't want to waste my shields.
I think we can just put a generator in here.
Yeah, we could.
You want to?
Start fencing all the doors, yeah.
Just put it wherever you think is safe.
Maybe like a...
Where do you want to put it?
Let me know where to put it.
This corner right here.
I'll throw this one.
I don't have fences yet, so I need to wait for cooldown.
I don't really know where the zone ends, but this is kind of the strategy.
We just sit and hope it ends on us.
Okay, I'm charging my thing.
Oh, there's no R9!
They're going southwest.
There's no R9!
If I run away from you guys, don't follow me.
I'm just doing this because I'm on Pathfinder.
Okay.
I'm not following you.
Me too.
How many fences can I put again?
Oh, okay, three more.
I'm going to put three more.
Three more.
I'm good.
I'm going to shot at it two times.
Two times?
I want it.
Wait, that guy has white armor.
Wait, the generator has infinite heals in this.
Yeah.
It's OG.
I'm mind blown.
I only have one fence left.
Charge.
There's like two or three squads in there.
I can only put very limited fences, so...
That's life, isn't it?
I could get rid of...
I have two ult accels on me.
I have two on me as well.
So I can put...
Alright, girls, you want me to fence here?
Hey, there's an R99 right here.
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
I pinged it.
Oh my god!
You ran past it like three times.
I ran past it like three times!
Where are they throwing grenades at?
I don't know.
Here it is.
You don't have to take it.
There's a team over there.
They're fighting in there.
Want me to come over?
Nope, nope, I'm good.
Nah, he hasn't told us to move yet.
You're right.
The IGL said nothing, so we do nothing.
Nope.
Bridge soldiers follow orders.
Why don't you have a syringe?
Yeah, you need it?
Wrong button.
Yeah, can I have it?
Alright.
Someone has the Kraber.
A Kraber?
I'm fucking dead.
They have a Kraber.
Why are you dead?
Because I have white armor.
Just... get blue.
Oh yeah?
Fucking whose body?
I hear someone taking a zip.
Doesn't the Kraber do more damage than this?
Yeah.
So I'm like, what the fuck do I do?
They're up there.
No they're not.
No, they are up there.
Oh yeah, they are.
Blue armor?
It's not fair, they have blue armor.
I have to beat the bitch, boy.
What do I...
Oh, I can put 3x on this.
Why can't I...
Why can't somebody with blue armor die next to us?
We really can't do anything now.
Because of this whole Kraber team.
Are they on the roof with Kraber?
Oh, LaunchKraber only did 125?
Is that true?
I thought LaunchKraber was strong.
They buffed the Kraber?
GawkGFart9k Oh, that's the gamer subs flavor that you can buy with my code DokiBird for 10% off.
LaunchKraber hit 210 for headshot.
125 the body.
Wait, they shot my thing.
Why'd you let them do that?
Oh, they're in, they're in.
Oh.
They have gold armor.
I don't know.
That is not good.
They're rushing.
They just walked right in.
My fences were broken and I was like, what?
And then they literally just shot me.
I was on the opposite side.
I literally heard my fence break.
Hey, it's Apex Classic.
No sound bro.
I heard my fence break and then I turned around and they were dead.
Oh, I guess we wait.
We all wait then.
It did not help.
That there was no sound.
Audio cue for either of us.
OG Apex.
I love OG Apex.
Oh my god.
They just got one shot.
I had white armor.
What the fuck was I supposed to do?
He had gold armor.
No, I just got L-starred.
L-starred 168.
Almost everyone I've shot has purple armor.
It's pretty insane.
I'm lucky or what?
I was so confused because I was like, what?
My fence broke.
And then it was like a distraction.
Skulltown.
Was Skulltown loot not good in OG Apex?
No.
It was terrible.
People just landed there because it was fun.
Shoot.
People landed there because it was good.
Skulltown loot was always bad.
People just landed there because everybody landed there and it was just a fun brawl session.
People just wanted fast fights and then you leave Skulltown.
I got timed out again?!
Noob down.
Wait, can you outheal this down in OG Apex?
Yes.
Yeah, if you're lifeline.
You about to do some rat shit?
Am I back in?
I'm back in.
Okay, thank god.
Bro, these cervicals are fucking ass.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna eat some popcorn.
Wait, you did 10 damage?
Or is that me?
No, there's no way that's me.
I did 10 damage.
Guys, I'm eating popcorn.
Chat, I need something in my life to make me happy.
Look at him go!
Okay.
Damn.
Look at him go, that's my goat.
Look at him go.
Guys, if I put my name at the bottom, it looks like I'm playing.
That guy's pretty good.
Thanks, that's me.
Surefour put up a web fishing queue.
Oh, Surefour is AFK.
Alright, I muted myself.
I muted myself so Verhulst could focus.
Bro, I'm so fucking tilted at the
server code shit.
Also, I'm sad I didn't get to shoot my gun.
I'm so sad.
I was so confused.
I was like, why did the fence break?
I thought it was a bug.
Oh no, but when you get to the final zone, it moves super fucking fast.
It's like a 3 second, it was like a 1 second move.
I'm just sad.
I couldn't even shoot my gun.
I didn't hear them walk up, and I was like, really?
Why did my fence break there?
They pushed me so fast I couldn't even react to it because I didn't hear the footsteps.
I just wanted to shoot my R9.
That's it.
I was so ready to.
If I was Wraith, I would have lived.
If I was Wraith, I could have lived.
At least we got third in that one game.
We just need Verhulst to keep ratting.
Did I get that crate?
Never meant to be.
Can't believe I couldn't get the R9.
I didn't even eat lunch you guys.
I woke up, went straight, had to do a lot of work.
Oh my god, I forgot to queue up.
Guys, the Fortnite video is done.
I'm supposed to upload it today.
Oh my god.
Within like... Damn, you still alive and kicking it.
40 minutes.
I can't upload it because I need to use the internet.
Welcome back, Surefour.
No problem.
Just live till top three so then we can get third place.
Surefour and I did nothing to deserve it but we still win money.
Bro, that's on you, motherfucker.
You just let those motherfuckers walk in.
I didn't hear anything either.
You didn't hear anything.
It wasn't on my side.
I was on your side when it happened.
Chill, chill, chill.
Sorry, you can focus.
We got one in the line here.
Oh yeah, the mastiff is fucking broken in this.
I'm just surprised you got rid of the R9.
I didn't have a mag for it.
Everybody is just wingmen.
Is that a rat?
Oh no.
There's a rat there.
There might be a full team ratting in the...
They're fighting back there.
I don't think I want to go this way.
I believe in you.
Yeah, we both believe in you.
Just hide in that tube.
Fuck it, bro.
What if a full team runs into that tube?
You can hide in the trees on this.
It's OG.
Oh yeah, you can hide in the trees.
Yeah.
You can literally hide in the trees.
He doesn't give a fuck.
He doesn't care about the trees.
He said, fuck the trees.
He has his own fucking plan.
Oh.
He is a pro player.
He knows more than us.
True.
He saw both of us die and he's just like, what the fuck are these kids doing?
He saw both of us die and then he's just like these guys don't know what they're talking about.
There's a little sneak peek over here.
There's a tree over there.
He doesn't give a fuck.
He wants kills.
He wants blood.
Uh oh.
He wants kills when kills don't matter.
Okay, that's toxic.
Remember,
you said...
I'm playing for glory.
Yeah, Mandy peer pressured him into this.
He doesn't give a fuck.
That's true, that's true.
He wants to hit a fucking clip, baby.
What's that YouTube video right there?
Carries two deadweights.
Carries two VTubers to victory.
Hey, I pull my weight when you fucking DC.
Can one of you stream snipe for me?
No, that's supposed to be a Discord message here.
Oh, I thought you guys were muted.
Wait, but you're not muted.
Oh, he's scared.
He thinks you're a full team.
Gulp.
Oh, landing.
Nevermind, that's ambient noises.
What the fuck?
That sounded like a landing jet.
Double Mastiff?
Whoa.
Wowee, Kraber Mastiff?
Mastiff Kraber?
Imagine.
Oh, Digi threat though.
Is that any good, bro?
It's alright.
I mean, I died by it.
I don't know.
I don't know if that's any good.
It has very limited ammo.
It's good, but ammo is very limited.
Oh, yeah.
I'm not running it.
Yeah, no, don't.
That's what I'm saying.
I ran that last time.
It was really good, but I basically couldn't fight at the end.
They fighting in there.
Seven squads left.
Oh, kill leader's dead.
I need to hold his rooftop.
Broken ass roof.
They'll think you're a full team.
Like, shoot with two different guns so they'll think you're two different people.
Yeah, shoot them with the Mastiff across the map.
Sounds like a good idea.
They'll know for sure.
They'll be like, oh man, the pro player wouldn't do that.
They're so scared.
They literally think you're a full team.
That's the plan.
Trying to scare them off.
Yeah, don't go this side.
This is basically a team of three for host.
Oh my god, yes.
Oh.
I think I scared them off.
Nice job.
I knew you could do it.
Like, what would you go after?
In a tree.
I mean, they're in the house because I see the gen.
That used to be our house.
Yeah.
Until somebody didn't hear the...
Won't say any names or anything.
Somebody didn't hear the sound of the...
Damn.
The guys on the other side don't give a fuck about you.
They're all just teaming up on the people zipping.
Like, what the fuck, you've been standing up there?
They haven't shot you once.
They're scared.
They saw his shots.
Oh, never mind.
There it is.
They're right below you.
There's one team.
That's just one guy.
Just like you.
Oh.
Did they know you're...
I hear Lifeline.
Never mind.
Oh, this guy knows how to play the video.
Wait, that's the team that killed me.
That's them.
You sure?
That guy had gold armor.
That was purple.
What's the game plan here?
I think I need to go to the middle of the ditch early.
Oh.
Whoa, there's a guy...
That sounds scary.
Yeah.
Everyone is shooting at you now.
They know.
They know who you are.
Oh.
Whoa.
There's somebody here.
Ah!
There's people in that area.
Blackpink in your area?
Oh, whoa!
He's a solo!
Wraith and Ashe?
We might need a bat now.
Oh, there's one in there.
Oh, you can shoot him.
No, no!
That was risky.
Oh!
No!
I just dodged that so bad.
That grapple was so bad.
Yeah, that grapple into him was crazy.
Yeah, I thought you were just going to...
I thought you were just going to AIM man him a bit.
Yeah.
I thought he was going to back up and I just keep shooting at him.
So I was going to try and grapple into his face and I completely botched that grapple.
He grappled into his L-Star.
That's crazy.
I was like, whoa!
Yeah.
I mean, you made a top 7.
He had a vision.
He had a vision right there.
It was close.
Pathfinder's grapple mechanics are different on this.
It is.
It is different.
In OG.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, the zone moves so fast.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
The zone is like...
And then the end zone is like literally...
Oh my god.
That poor team.
Uh oh.
Oh, he can't climb!
He can't climb!
He's so dead!
I'll pretend to be part of this team!
Be their friend!
Be their friend, Pathfinder!
He got away with it.
Oh my god, he actually got away!
He might get 3rd out of this.
Oh, that's crazy!
He's getting 3rd out of that.
Why isn't he medding, though?
Because they can hear the sound.
They can hear it.
If he meds, they might be able to hear the med kit.
Or maybe he ran out of meds.
He should have done it during all the fighting.
Oh my god, he's actually going to get 3rd because of it.
He might not have any meds.
He's probably been sitting in his zone the entire game.
I mean, their Gibraltar was on white armor.
That's true.
I think I just armor swapped it, though.
He's got 2.5k damage, though.
Yeah.
Oh, he's getting 3rd.
Or even 2nd, maybe.
What the fuck?
Where did that come from?
Oh my god.
No!
Oh my god!
You're so stupid!
You just don't look down!
Well, they think their behind is completely clear at this point.
That's crazy.
The moment he gets spotted, there's like one poke.
It's one body shot and he's fucking dead.
The motherfucker doesn't even have his gun out.
Oh, they get 3rd.
They get money.
Dead.
Pineapple pizza.
Oh, it's still hard.
Look at this guy.
It was just two rats!
Gamers never look down.
Oh my god.
Alright, last two games.
He told us this was going to end at 3.
Yeah, well, you knew what you were getting into.
I did.
I knew.
I was like, that's very ambitious when I saw that.
Someone told you it was going to end at 3?
Yeah, they said it was going to end at 3 and I was like, that's so ambitious.
I was like, there's no way it's going to end at 3.
I knew it was not.
I was like, a tournament custom with 6 games is like 3-4 hours.
I just realized, Strike and Flame and MT, you're on a team?
What is that?
Game 5, weapon lock.
Weapon selection.
Mandi will stream live on stream to select two weapon categories.
Participants must use weapons from these categories for the entire game.
Yeah.
I hope it's...
I hope it's sniper.
I want a sniper.
Can we do...
Can we do hitscan charge rifle?
You can't revert it back.
You can't.
There's no way to revert the guns.
I want hitscan charge rifle now.
Then I'm going to rename myself to charge king.
I wish you can do that.
I wish you can bring back old guns.
That was so fun.
Just solo queueing to rank.
Getting to friend players and just shooting them out of the air.
Who was our third?
We did a full charge rifle.
I think it was Gully.
Was it Gully?
Yeah, we won all charge rifle and it actually griefed Timmy.
He got so mad on stream about us.
I remember that shit.
I was on top of the windmill.
No, the uh...
The watermill?
Yeah, it was the watermill.
You kept fucking griefing Timmy and his game.
Yeah, Timmy and Asu.
Oh yeah, it was Timmy and Asu!
Wait, what was it?
They re-rolled?
LMGs and shotguns.
What's an LMG?
Newcastle, Lifeline, and Gibby are banned.
LMG guns.
LMGs and shotguns?
You gotta be kidding me.
Wait, what guns are those?
What's in the LMG category?
Spitfire, Rampage, Devotion, L-Star.
I'll run the Spitfire.
Spitfire is probably the best option.
Yeah, and then...
Spitfire and...
Is L-Star an LMG?
Wait, you can use Rampart?
They're allowing Rampart, Sheila.
Oh!
Wait, I can do Vantage, and I can just snipe people.
Wait, what do we play?
For host?
Give us your wisdom.
The same comp...
Same comp that we did game...
Horizon.
Yeah, Bang Horizon.
Pathfinder.
Alright.
Okay.
In the rules, I said they're gonna ban Legends from game 3, so it would be 6 bans, not 3.
Yeah, somebody called them out on it.
Sometimes people lie.
Oh, and then Maddie's like, nah, nevermind.
Maddie didn't give a fuck.
No, they literally went, these guys have failed picking heroes 5 million times, adding 3 more to it is gonna make it impossible for these motherfuckers to win.
That's so true.
We've already are almost an hour over time.
You got some plans tonight?
Path of Exile.
A Boonstone fight.
My second stream.
Let's see.
Oh, so we're gonna do Bang Path and...
Oh, what was it?
Bang Path and...
Okay, Bang Path, Horizon.
And you're gonna DC.
And I went DC, and you guys are gonna play again without me.
Yeah.
Only the top 3 teams win.
So no kills.
Kills don't matter.
That being said, we're killing everybody.
Wait, kills don't matter?
Should we play zone then?
When everyone's playing zone, we counter the lobby.
Oh, okay.
I get it, I get it.
Trust, trust.
I don't know what's up with this server.
I keep DCing.
I don't really know how to play zone, I'm not gonna lie.
I only know how to like...
Oh, you're not the zone reader, right?
Nope.
Wait, who's the zone reader on your team?
Well, we kind of all read zones, but our team has always played edge.
Oh, so you're just the fragger.
Yeah, yeah.
You're just there to frag.
We're known as the team that's like, we'll just run it down.
We just grief people.
Oh, so you believe in us to be able to do that, basically.
Oh, yeah.
I'm assuming that we are the best fighting team in this lobby.
You know what?
I believe, I agree too.
Even though I wasn't there in match 3, I agree with that.
Imagine if Yogi was there, just hard carrying us that game.
Yeah, while I was fishing, while I was fishing, that was just all me.
It's the same map again.
Or, e-district again.
Oh, okay.
Oh, it is!
It's basically a repeat!
Let's go!
Same strategy, we're just gonna int face.
Is it starting?
Start the lobby.
They said start in 10 seconds.
Oh, Rampart is banned.
Apparently.
Rampart is banned.
Rampart, Gibby, Newcastle.
Dang, why did he ban Rampart?
Because people were planning on using Rampart with the gun lock.
Yeah, I would recommend Spitfire.
I would do Spitfire, L-Star, Rampage, Devotion, in that order.
Okay.
We're trying to pick LMGs.
Spitfire's the best.
Okay.
Rampage ain't bad, though.
If you get some Thermites for the Rampage, it's actually the best.
But you need Thermites.
Yeah, but that's a little too much work.
Yeah, that's a lot of work.
Where is the angle door?
Let's go.
I'm feeling a massive W here.
I think this is our map.
Oh, yeah.
This is it.
This is where we're gonna win.
There's gonna be no disconnects.
We're gonna hear all the Apex audio.
And then, Evan's gonna get like 500 kills for us.
Yeah, that's what we like to see.
Yes, yes, yes.
If he doesn't get 500 kills, he gets kicked off of TSM.
Oh, let's go!
Let's freaking go!
Ah, Sheeper.
Looks like no one's landing here.
I'm going to my slot.
I can't wait for like when...
The moment we touch the ground, it ends the match.
Someone has picked the wrong hero.
Oh, wait, you can.
Should you pick up the right guns?
I just picked up an alternator.
Oopsies.
I have control and I'm not picking up the guns I can't use.
Alright, I need to find a master.
I got my shotgun LMG.
I found...
Oh, I got a Spitfire.
Zero weapons.
Oh, no!
I'm so cursed.
I'm getting off.
Our entire team just leaves.
Just don't let them play!
I freaking fished!
I'm...
We need some monetary...
That's two days we get hot zone and they restart.
They didn't restart for me!
I literally fished!
I fished and it was okay with me!
Let them fish!
No, somebody crashed.
It was Zero.
ZeroPlus crashed.
Somebody picked Gibraltar.
Wait, somebody picked Gibraltar?
Wait, you're right!
Somebody picked Gibraltar.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Who was H.A.
Hakeem?
It was Pariah Carey.
Who the fuck was it?
I'm starting to get mad.
Let's all just leave.
I'm going on strike.
Never again.
We're never coming back.
It's your fault.
Why don't we all leave and just play quick play?
Names are fine.
You guys want to go grind for predator after this?
Yeah, sure.
Let's just leave now and do it.
We can do it in a night, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, if we win a couple games.
They're starting the server and Giga is missing too.
They're just done.
Toxky.
Oh my god, are we?
No, just started.
Please!
When's your second stream even supposed to be?
I'm playing a fan game.
My fans made me a game.
No, they cannot.
I refuse.
It's not going anywhere.
Are you trying to say my time is not important?
Yeah.
Wow.
VTubers are weird.
They make stream plans.
They stream on YouTube and they have things called waiting rooms where they schedule the streams.
Each stream is themed around the game that we're playing on.
Unlike Twitch, we can't just swap games and then change the category.
How long have we been here for?
We've been streaming for two hours and 43 minutes.
Doki's reaching her breaking point.
That's not true.
She's literally about to be working overtime.
I have a second stream.
They stream for like two or three hours.
That's true, though.
A lot of VTubers on YouTube just usually go like two to three hours because that's our stamina.
Oh man, that was a long stream today, guys.
Good stream, guys.
I'm going to go on a week break now.
That's not me.
You guys are non-stop high energy.
Yeah, because we stream two to three hours.
We have the energy to do that.
I'm at the nine-hour mark and I'm about to fall asleep.
You're at the nine-hour mark?
Oh yeah, you had like scrims.
Yeah, I had scrims at nine in the morning.
This custom is like right after like...
Our hotspot is gone, guys.
Our hotspot's gone.
We literally are so far.
We're not even going to reach the building.
Some of the Hololive VTubers haven't streamed in like two months.
Yeah, but they have passive income.
Dude, that must be lit.
Why?
We don't even have hotspots.
Why are they contesting us all of a sudden?
I'm pretty sure they're going Galleria.
We don't even have hotspots.
It looks like they're fucking...
No, they're coming.
Why are they coming here all of a sudden, bro?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
We've raced to the top.
Alright, I can queue us.
Well, they have to get the guns.
They can't fight us if they don't have the guns.
Oh my god, let's hope we find the guns for this first.
I don't have a shotgun.
I don't have a gun.
There's a Spitfire right here.
I'll give it to you guys because one of you guys need a gun.
Grab the Spitfire.
I'll come to that in a sec.
What's wrong with them?
I grabbed the Spitfire.
There's another Spitfire up here.
Okay, grab it.
This team probably just dipped out.
What the fuck is wrong with them?
They landed on us and just dipped?
What kind of fucking nerds?
I don't see them.
I don't see them either, but I'm scared.
I'm not.
He said we need to...
I mean, they haven't dropped the whole time.
Now they're dropping now.
Which team is it?
I'm starting to get angry.
I dropped down.
I'm looking.
I'm pretty sure they just ran away.
What the fuck is wrong with them?
They thought we would veer and be bitches, but we fucking held our ground.
Yeah.
The server is lagging.
I'm spiking to 100 ping.
Oh no, you got the curse.
Now it's your turn.
Uh oh.
The zone might be on top of our heads.
Oh.
I'm going to be next to Rahul so I know I'm protected.
So I know I can feel safe.
I'll take it.
I'm next to you so I can be safe.
I'm looting so I can die.
It's alright.
If you die in Apex, you die in real life.
Eva here.
Eva is typically better than the PK.
I have the Mastiff.
Okay, that's good.
Can we go together?
Oh my god, this Eva is crazy.
Where do we go?
Nobody is dead.
Everybody is tired.
Maybe we should sit on our building for a bit.
The zone might be on us.
We have nothing though.
If the zone is on us, we're going to have regretted moving.
I feel like people would be on us already.
People rotate fucking fast.
It's got to be a stadium zone if it's not pointing to us.
I feel like if it was on us, there would be like 200 people already.
It seems we're here.
I need a scope.
We don't have Evas close by.
We got really unlucky with Evo spawns.
We have a ring console here.
Let's go get this Eva over here.
I'm running.
We'll come back.
I'll wait.
I think the zone is to our south.
I'm not sure.
It's time to edge.
Where the fuck is the door if we're here?
Hello Ice King.
Yo, what's good?
Could be better.
Spitfire has a fucking...
It's a guy in front of me.
It's a Wraith.
We're here too.
He was over here.
He ran into this alleyway.
That'd be a solo.
I'm not sure.
Where is his team?
I feel like his team could be nearby.
I hear him sliding.
On the outside of this thing.
I think it's a solo Wraith.
I swear to God.
He just...
Watch out.
On the left.
Oh, I got hit.
Life flash.
I downed one.
I can't see shit.
He charged that.
I need a heal.
It's just one left.
That's on you.
You got this, right?
Cracked him.
Come to me when you can.
Yeah, I'm grabbing his shield.
I'm here.
Hey, it's code Mandy.
I need a heal.
Heal him.
There we go.
Where's the other guy that died?
Oh, there he is.
He has a Spitfire too.
I need a light mag if you see.
Nope.
Man, these guys have light mags.
That's pretty cursed.
Nope.
No light mag.
Light mags.
Where's the guy you killed?
Let's get the Evo here.
He's under you.
Oh, it's fine.
I don't need his body.
It's useless to me.
Oh, that's the first team!
That's the first team that died!
That's right.
Now you gotta watch us because there's still one more game left.
This team might look ridiculous here.
Yeah.
There's a team literally in the stadium here.
Can we go hit this beacon?
I'm with you.
We're right behind you.
They're close here.
No, they could be around the corner.
I'm wearing my mask.
There's a Loba ult right there.
They're right across here.
Or left.
That guy!
He's in the back corner.
You can kill him.
No, you can't.
Behind me!
No way.
That's a different team.
Strike it out.
Just run for your life.
That's a different team.
Just run.
What?
That's a different team!
What were they doing there?
They were ratting the beacon.
They were literally just ratting there.
We were about to hit the man stand too.
Oh my god.
They like hid in the fucking corner.
And now they're gonna fucking die.
They're gonna die for it!
I hate VTubers.
Oh my god.
That's so fucked.
I can't believe they ratted that.
Holy shit.
That is unfortunate.
That is so unfortunate.
We were about to hit the man stand.
Why do you camp?
That's crazy.
And they're gonna survive too because...
Because they just need to craft him.
But they're so split up.
Hello darkness my old friend.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe we got ratted.
That's battle royales bro.
You live and die by the rats.
If we had an EvoCache...
Anywhere near us...
We wouldn't have gotten ratted on because I would have hit the heights beacon.
Yeah, if...
You know, if that person didn't pick fucking Gibraltar.
By the way, the team that picked Gibraltar died already.
Like died at like 19th place.
So it's like...
What was the point of restarting?
They already got knocked down!
Anyway...
They got knocked down in the restart.
I think it's the server.
The server code is like...
Why does he not shoot back?
Just shoot back.
He's so scared.
Oh, he's got teammates.
That's why.
I don't think those were teammates.
No, he got knocked.
So he was a teammate.
He got knocked though.
Mythic supply bin.
Get this team out.
They killed us.
Oh my god.
Get him out!
That's for killing us.
There was no reason to kill us there.
Wait, what the fuck?
They had two knocks?
Oh, because there's another third party.
We got greased so hard.
That's karma, exactly.
Next match is...
Melee and grenades.
I feel like we have to play Wattson.
Melee and grenades?
Oh jeez.
I guess I can play Fuse, unless you want Fuse.
No, I can play Wattson.
Do they ban Fuse?
I mean, I guess Horizon is good for that.
Because then you can also go in the air to dodge all the nades.
That's true.
But do we not want the Wattson ult for the...
Yeah, but doesn't Wattson ult stop your own grenades?
Yeah, but then it stops their grenades too.
I will be playing Wraith.
Wraith and Ashe?
Yep.
Just for endgame.
That's true.
You got the phase.
Oh, someone should play Crypto.
Wait, I can play Crypto and just like...
Why is Crypto good?
Because I can EMP all the Wattson ults.
I don't think they're going to allow damage dealing abilities.
I don't think so.
You have to ask them.
I'd ask them about Crypto.
Okay, so then Wattson can't put fences then.
We're not allowed to.
Well, I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't know if they're allowing damage dealing abilities or not.
We can ask them now since we're AFK.
Okay.
Our best game was literally the first ALGS game.
We were fucking farming there.
And then we get fucking ratted.
What sucks is that I always get shot first too.
So stupid.
I'm always the one that gets shot first.
I instantly just exploded on you.
Like, why me?
Why did they pick me?
They could have picked anybody else.
I'm the only one that's like the worst pick.
To get targeted.
Oh, each team must use Pathfinder, Octane, and Bloodhound.
Oh.
Okay.
I didn't know that.
I guess I'll do...
I'll do...
Wait, what the fuck?
Why Bloodhound?
I guess scanning?
Octane's gonna be completely useless.
Jump pad!
You can jump pad people.
I guess you could try and jump pad somebody in the zone.
Yeah, it's jump pad and then arc star.
Oh yeah, no, no, that's basically it.
You throw jump pads in the final circle.
So it causes everybody to jump into the zone.
Would you rather play Octane or Bloodhound?
Uh...
Alright, so we're winning this next one, right?
Yeah, sure, you want Octane, Bloodhound, or Path?
Wait, what do we need Bloodhound for?
Well, it's locked in.
It's locked in.
I can be the blue hunter.
Alright.
I'm good with either Octane or Pathfinder.
If you have a preference.
We'll play Pathfinder again.
Alright, then I'll do Octane.
I'm going to throw jump pads at people.
So...
You guys should know that Pathfinder's purple zipline.
It makes you take half damage if you get the purple perk.
Yeah.
And that also applies to the zone.
So if you put a Pathfinder zipline at the end of the game and just take it.
The zone will deal half damage.
Oh, that's so smart, but then everybody else is going to take your zipline.
I mean, yeah.
Everyone's going to be running ziplines at the end.
Everyone's going to take it.
The key will just be dodging all the grenades on the ground at the end of the game.
I don't know how we're going to do that.
I'm going to kill myself and throw arc stars on the ground.
I'm going to do that and see how many people die from it.
Alright, so one of you guys in game.
Can you still stick arc stars to teammates?
No.
We could have done an OG.
We could have done that in OG.
Why didn't we do that?
Just send Oki in?
Yeah, you could have sent me in.
I was going to die anyway.
Oh my god.
They stole his rez.
Shoot him.
Shoot the guy rezzing.
If you shot him earlier.
He didn't reload his shotgun.
Unless...
Oh my god.
Movement.
He died for it.
He should have just committed.
He knew he was going to die.
He did it.
Oh, this guy could get third place.
Yeah, that thing is freaking out.
Yeah, because it was...
Oh.
No money for you.
Hey, at least we got third place that one time.
Yeah.
That was definitely there for it.
Who is this guy I'm spectating anyway?
Who is he?
I don't know, but they're on a controller.
That's true, it's drifting.
Someone, please.
Someone who is playing the tournament, please open my stream.
So you can see this guy.
No.
It's technically not stream sniping.
Because I'm technically dead.
They're a controller player.
He could.
He could get third.
He's literally playing for placements.
He's rat jamming.
He's jamming, alright.
He's interchanging.
Doubting his next play.
Oh, movement, movement.
Movement!
Is anyone casting this?
Yeah, Mandy is casting.
Tell us who this guy is.
If you find out.
Can you find a nice little rat spot?
There's one more solo in the lobby.
He needs to find that solo.
Pretty sure that solo is to his right.
Over there?
No, like straight to his west.
On the zone.
This is a pretty good spot though.
This is insane.
What?
Oh my god.
Wait, he's actually going to get third.
Oh, they got the other rat.
He's one placement away.
It's a rat, a duo, and a...
two three mans, I think.
Looks like the other team is about to die.
But then can he win the 1v3?
Yep.
Now he's third.
Wait, whoop.
Wait, he might get second.
I'm pretty sure one team is a duo.
So it's just who gets spotted first.
The duo or the solo.
Wait, Maday DC'd his own fucking custom?
No way.
No fucking way.
He DC'd his own custom.
That's so funny.
Guys, I think they need a new code.
I think they need a new code.
Are these like...
No, they're not because we have to fly.
These are like literally like public codes.
Because I was like wondering if they're like dev...
Not dev codes, but like priority codes.
Now it's grenades and punching.
Yep.
All right.
Chill, guys.
Whose team was that?
Oh, I think it was enemy.
Yeah, that was enemy then.
Oh, FSH won two in a row.
SFH?
Whoa, rigged.
100% rigged.
They have two pro players.
I mean...
Yeah, they have two pros.
It is rigged.
Every time we get a hotspot, they restart.
Exactly!
We actually could have won at least two games.
We could have won two games.
We've been pretty cursed.
We got Rattalon, we got Doki D.C.
I got D.C.
Hot zones going away.
We lost two hot zones.
Audio.
That duo running at us in epicenter.
Yeah, that duo griefing us by landing in a draw spot.
Can't wait.
If I make it to end zone, I'm taking all my nades.
Give me all your nades and I'm throwing it in the center.
Wait, but we need nades too.
No, you guys don't.
You guys gotta heal off.
If I throw all the nades...
I'm the blue hunter.
If you throw the nades at the center, you're gonna get hurt.
By your own nades.
But if I throw it, you won't get hurt.
But you'll get hurt.
Yeah, that's why I'm sacrificing myself for the greater good.
I'll be a hero.
I wanna be a hero.
Alright, then you fucking do it.
Yippee!
I think at the end of the game, there's gonna be so many octane jump pads.
Oh yeah, 100%.
Everybody's just gonna put a jump pad surrounding.
Alright, how much do we bet there's a restart?
It's always a restart.
You guys are gonna have to stay alive on those octane jump pads, tap strafing, because I can't tap strafe off those.
I can tap strafe.
It's gonna be up to you guys.
In the endgame, keep tap strafing off the jump pads over and over again.
And then, when the zone closes all the way, just hop on somebody's zipline until the game ends.
And I might just end up being the one punching.
What if I can't do that?
What if I fail?
No, I can tap strafe.
I'm just saying, what if I can't do it continuously?
Well, if you can't kill yourself, you can just come down with me and start swinging.
Alright, sure, it's all you.
It's all you.
We do want to look for kills throughout the game.
Until we get to endgame, we're gonna try and just three-man run people down.
Wait, it is ALGS points.
For this one, it is.
Oh, for this one.
I thought the other ones too.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Only this one.
Come on, this is the last game.
We're one hour over time.
Who's munching right now?
Me, I'm munching on my caramel popcorn.
I didn't eat lunch yet.
And it's gonna be dinner soon.
You didn't eat?
No.
Wait, what did we claim?
What the hell is with girls and just never eating?
Women, am I right?
Okay, I wasn't going that route.
I'm woman.
Cause I woke up, I had to do I had one hour left to do work stuff and then work and walk my dog and then I had to go straight to this tournament.
As I can say, I'm woman.
I don't eat sometimes.
No, that's not true.
I do eat but I fuck up my eating schedule a lot.
I never.
You never eat?
I eat at the same times every day.
Really?
You have a schedule?
I wake up at 8pm and then after stream.
What happens if you don't follow your schedule?
Do you just combust?
I literally die.
Guys, remember you're like a Tamagotchi.
If someone forgets to feed me, I start dying.
He just disappears.
Wait, what if we all go Ceto?
Yeah, what if we all do that?
You're right.
What if we all do that?
Just pick the Mac with the fucking boxing ring and send everyone in.
Apparently, it's removed.
What?
Yeah, I removed it because it's not in rotation.
This is fucked up.
This is such a fucked up day.
You almost got out of this custom.
Who, me?
You, yeah.
You weren't even supposed to be here.
Listen, that's life, isn't it?
Well, we got like money out of it at least.
How much did we even get?
I don't know.
Did he even tell us how the prize money is divided?
Yeah, but obviously, first place gets more of the money.
We should probably get like $50.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
Did we just get $50 or some shit?
Maybe $25.
$50 each?
Oh my god, we're eating tonight.
Just gonna order a bunch of McDonald's.
And then I'm gonna fucking use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
I don't know when we're starting.
Right now?
No way.
I lied by the way.
Because I didn't have my character picked.
So I'd be the reason why we restart.
That'd be lit.
Okay, I'm gonna attempt fate.
We're gonna have to restart.
It's actually starting.
Oh god.
Doki's gonna pick the wrong character.
It's all over.
Better hurry your ass up.
Okay, I'm on oof hunter.
Where the fuck is... there he is.
Well, she's picking last.
So she has a chance.
She has a chance.
Oh, I see her moving her mouse.
Let's go.
Back, thank fucking god.
You're lucky you were picking last.
I mean, we're gonna have to restart anyways.
Wait, no, you're right.
You're right, we're gonna have to restart anyway.
What was the point?
What fucking map are we on?
There's cars.
Wait, they didn't say no cars!
They said no cars.
Yeah, they said no cars.
There it is.
Alright.
Who dc'd?
Why is it every match?
VTubers, am I right?
What was the point?
I rushed.
We should blacklist all of them.
If you dc'd, you're never invited back.
The technology just isn't there.
20 more years of AI development.
Still hard.
Team Hakeem again?!
They did it again?!
Who was it?
It was.
Was it actually?
Oh my god, you're right, it is.
Are they a VTuber?
Who are they?
Alright, I'm finding them.
Yeah, get the detection work going in.
No, they're not!
They are the content creator category!
They're part of your category!
They're your people.
Control your people.
Control your fleshy fleshmen.
Oh, Fun also fucking trolled.
It was Fun that picked the catalyst.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Fleshies, am I right?
Fucking pro players.
Always ruining everything.
Sleeping at the wheel.
I can't believe it.
I used the bathroom so fucking fast and there was no reason to.
I could have just let the world take me.
I
think if you keep taking a zipline over and over again you'll just never die to grenades.
Yeah, but you can only take it twice.
Oh, you're dead.
Restart again?
Oh, we're starting!
Restarting!
He's gonna get all the kills to everyone that has his own.
There's gonna be heat shields too, I think, by the way.
Oh yeah, we get heat shields!
If we actually end up using all six of our heat shields we'll just win the game for free.
We each get to carry two.
Wait, really?
I'm last pick again.
So if we find three heat shields, we're looking real good.
Yay!
I'm ready.
What are my skills?
I want an extra launch pad charge.
Change directions with the launch pad double charge.
You guys pick what you want for those characters.
That's not my expertise.
Alright, Ice King is right here.
Nobody goes Devastate Coast, we can split loot all of it too.
That's true.
What if I just go there?
What if I land on somebody and knock them out and then you craft me?
That's crazy.
Do we have crafters?
Wait, do we have crafters?
We don't have crafters.
Hey, you almost freaking griefed.
I just wanted to fucking beat someone up.
One of you can land on each dock and I'll loot the...
I'll loot this one.
I'll loot over here.
Yeah, there's people landed there.
I could've landed on these guys and you guys could've crafted me if I had a crafter.
Guys,
I don't even find any grenades.
Me too.
Butterfly knife.
That's cool.
Can I put a fucking scope on my grenade?
Like a drone?
Fucking drone somebody.
Yeah.
I haven't found a single grenade.
I have like... I have four.
I have a lot of nades.
Do you want some of my nades?
Yeah.
Holy shit.
Yeah,
I'll give you some nades.
There's no nades up here.
I wanna die.
Bro, here.
I threw you some nades.
So it'd be less sad for you.
I scanned.
There's like people here.
I think that's where people are fighting.
Did you pick up my nades?
Yeah.
Alright.
Good job.
What if like I just hold a gun but not use it?
That'd be weird.
It's just to freak people out.
It shows you don't have self-restraint.
I do.
I have a bigger self-restraint by not shooting my gun that I'm holding.
Nah.
Cause you still picked it up.
Where do we go?
I've been...
Loot all the bones up here.
Just keep looting.
I'm gonna ask you guys for some shields.
I didn't really get to loot too much over here.
Oh, I have more nades.
Pick up lots of shields.
I only have one battery.
Alright.
I have a lot.
I have three phoenix kits if anyone wants any.
I don't have a backpack either.
Pick a backpack for me.
Here's a blue one.
Oh, I got dibbed.
You carry backpacks?
No, I was just gonna pick one for me.
Oh, I grabbed it.
I'm gonna look for this evo up here.
There's more shields here.
Someone just scanned up there.
Take my nade here cause I'm getting meds.
Someone's gonna die on me.
We're getting naded.
I'm heading up.
I'm getting ran at.
Really?
I have a jump pad.
Is there?
I'm here with you.
Oh, there he is.
I'm getting ran at.
Come, come, come, help me.
Yeah, I'm here, I'm here.
Wait, we can take them all to you.
Kill this guy.
I'm here.
Oh.
There you go.
I cracked him.
He's out.
Oh, come here, come here, come here.
Oh, I think we gotta craft you.
I'm leaving so we can craft you.
Why did you not help me?
There's literally, we're at two teams.
Why am I sacrificed to the wolves?
Let's go craft.
Let's find a crafter.
I can't outrun a fucking octane, man.
Yeah, he's just fucking chasing.
Doki, you gotta help.
Wait, what?
He's still chasing.
He's weak, Doki.
Kill him, kill this guy.
No, I can't because his teammates are here.
Yeah, I'm fucking mighty dead then.
You guys didn't tell me he was chasing.
I literally was not paying attention.
Uh-oh.
Oh, this is bad.
The closest crafter is really far.
Godspeed, soldier.
It's a crafter command center.
Yeah, but they might chase.
Oh, they're 100% gonna chase.
How many white meds do you have?
I have four syringes and five shield cells.
I mean, I could do here.
I would just go hit the crafter.
You could maybe call us in in the zone on top command center.
Yeah.
What if I die in the zone?
That would be so awkward.
That would be so Akko-Takko.
That would be pretty funny, though.
I hear people.
Yep.
I might be dead.
Nah, they're not gonna chase, bro.
I could try cascades.
Yeah, just go look for it.
I don't want a full syringe.
I feel like that's so risky.
If I run into a team.
What are they gonna do?
Punch you?
All three of them can punch me and I just...
Nope.
And there's a team in front of you.
That's what I'm thinking about.
Why did you guys have to die?
You didn't help me!
Or him!
I did!
I had to help Verhulst and then I had to turn around I had to help you!
I was left to the fucking wolves!
Like, what do you expect me to do?
I had to turn around twice!
I'm fucking dead.
I'm gonna go straight back to command center.
Oh my god, they're running after me.
I can't.
They're literally running after me.
My death is on your shoulders.
I'm a ghost.
Back to cascades then.
Like, they're literally right behind me.
The only other crafter in zone 2 is pylon.
That'll be your only other option once zone closes.
Like, I can't!
Wait, did he shoot you?
No, he punched me.
How the fuck is he behind you?
Because he slid!
But you were sliding.
He's a pathfinder!
Eh, you'll be fine.
Oh my god!
I hate this!
If they hit just one arcstar...
That's all they needed.
Oh no, Docting's coming over too.
The Octane's coming over as well.
Oh, he's juicing.
Yo, take the fucking thing!
I'm gonna take it!
You can take it and throw it at your feet.
If you've any nades, throw them at your feet and they chase you.
Throw them on the bottom of the platform Yeah, right here.
Bro.
They want you.
They really want me.
One more hit!
One more!
I told you!
Docting, you're supposed to clutch off!
What do you mean?!
I fucked up my tap stream!
This dude has fucking...
Red armor!
They actually got evo shield!
I panicked.
I messed up my tap stream.
Bro, I was left at a 1v3.
I had to save for host and then I had to turn around for you!
Don't fucking care!
You didn't even save him.
You watched him fucking die.
I saved him and I didn't realize they were still chasing him!
All I'm saying is...
It was definitely not my fault.
It was not my fault.
It seems you've come for you again.
Somebody else died first.
I had zero craft.
I could go to zero crafters.
Happens.
GG's guys.
GG's!
I am gonna...
I'm gonna call it here.
I have my other stream.
Are you gonna play Path of Exile?
Probably.
What about you bro host?
What's your day gonna be like?
I will be eating some dinner.
What are you gonna eat?
I got some...
Papa cooked salmon.
Wow!
Sounds good.
Yummy.
I need to order my one meal today.
Alright, GG's guys.
GG's.
I don't really care who wins this game.
GG's everybody.
GG's.
Bye bye.
Oh my god.
That wasn't my fault.
That we lost there.
The last game.
Even if I saved for wholesome time.
We would have died anyway.
Because we had a full team chasing us.
I literally made the best of the situation.
To be fair, I literally didn't hear him say help.
I just heard...
I heard Surefour said help, but I was just like it's over Surefour.
We're fucking leaving.
There's no way.
There's two teams on us.
There's no fucking way we can do anything.
Anyway.
No, this event was so cursed.
Because everything...
We lost our two hot drops.
I dc'd.
In the middle of it.
And then what else happened?
So many shit happened.
Yeah, they chased me for half...
They chased me for so fucking long.
They did.
There was four other teams.
There were...
I literally ran into four different teams.
And this one team chased me through all of them.
Yeah, anyway guys.
I have another stream in 30 minutes.
So I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go prep for that stream.
I will see you guys...
I'm gonna break the other stream.
I'll see you guys there everybody.
GG's everyone.
Thanks for playing with me.
Well, it was randomized.
That was not randomized.
He requested to be on my team.
But yeah.
GG's everyone.
Stay hydrated.
And you stay up for me.
Stay up for a little longer.
Because we have a second stream later.
Bye bye guys.
Bye.